I'm pretty sure.
Can you hear us?
Chad, can you hear us?
Hello.
Hello, hello everybody.
Testing one, two, three.
Can you go live?
These are live.
Nice.
Okay.
Hello, Doki's Chad.
Hey, guys.
It only took 15 years, but we did manage to get here in the
end.
Wow.
When did Doki become British?
Wait.
Guys.
Guys, I don't want to...
Oh my God, Doki Bird, you're British?
And also, I guess Rin is now Canadian.
What's up, gamers?
It's me, John Doki Bird.
Back at it again with another banger stream.
Yeah, that's definitely my intro.
That's definitely Doki's intro, guys.
John Doki Bird is pretty good.
Would you like your soul to return to your body?
Oh, sure.
That would be great.
Would you like your soul to return to your body?
FPS games.
I'm the best FPSer that ever did FPS.
She says it so often.
Oh, wait.
What's a knock?
Oh, no.
Hello.
Oh, hey.
Thank you.
Thank you to, um, Oh, sweet.
I'm Lee's mom for giving us.
Thanks, mom.
Thanks, I'm Lee's mom for giving me.
Yeah, we're definitely with I'm a leave right now.
How are we?
It's so weird that all three of us are here.
here at the same time at the same place pretty crazy on
amelie's setup like i slept with my ryan a flight yeah my
scuffed setup yeah it's so weird and it's on my channel it's
a hell of a scuffed something is secret desperately wrong i
want to want to be known that we saw the comments that were
like huh it must be omelie's fault that there's so much yeah
but we'll figure you know it was i don't want to let you
know that it was rin's fault yeah it was actually nothing
she was late lost.
They agreed to conspire against me before we started.
He was the one who had to take 20 minutes trying to remember
the password to my YouTube channel.
There were so many passwords.
But also, after I found out my password, I still had to wait
for Rin.
That's what was Rin doing out of interest.
I'd love to know.
You were in the bathroom for like 20 minutes.
We were so concerned.
We were like of you, is it?
What would you ever think?
We were trying to text you.
but you we could hear like you're playing phone games in the
bathroom so we'd be concerned do you know you can get
hemorrhoids from that if you're staying too long it has been
two minutes two minutes but yes we can't unfortunately we
can't we were just here on vacation at the same right
definitely complete coincidence just so random we just like
ran into each other on the street i was like wait a second
that voice sounds familiar yeah and it's We were all talking
to ourselves going down the street.
We didn't have chat to bounce off.
Rin was behind me.
I didn't notice.
I was like, we're all here.
My God, what a coincidence.
I'm in this close location.
They just heard me like four streets over going, and you
guys ran Totskir as well.
That's crazy.
Wow.
Oh no, I wasn't meant to say that, was I?
Oh my God, we're in Ireland.
Leaks, leaks.
We're in Washington State.
We're in Quebec right now.
We're everywhere.
We're in the Atlantic open.
We're in.
We could be anywhere, honestly.
It could be...
Where in the world are the V-tubers?
We're coming to you straight from the middle of the Bermuda
Triangle.
San Diego.
We're actually on a plane right now.
We're in the sky.
We're on a private jet.
Guys, there's no pilot.
They're trusting me to drive the plane.
If you're a V-tuber, and you're a V-tuber, and I'm a
V-tuber, then who's flying the plane?
Alright, who's this?
We have a what?
Oh, we have a stream echo?
Oh.
Sorry, that was Rin's mom.
Echo.
Famously.
Uh, oh, it's, it's, we're both in this source and this
source.
Oh, we're both in this testing.
Sorry, we were not.
No, we were, I don't know.
I don't know.
We have a song.
That one's the music on the mic.
Oh my God, wait.
What if my stream is playing on top?
And they called me the scuff queen.
Hey, I had to figure all this out.
You did have to log into 85 times and reset your password
and it was really giving me hives over here.
I was really glad that it wasn't me.
I will, this is a little hint, I have to do all of this and
the entire PC was not in the English language.
It was not in the English language.
And they're like, are you sure you could do this?
I think I can run this.
Honestly, Hacker Boys, Joki was like, I'm in.
Because I'm watching her like in OBS, click all these
buttons.
And I'm like, how do you know that's the right butt?
Like, she's like, can you have a muscle memory baby?
Yeah, I was just like muscle memory of all the times I had
to do OBS.
Actually, a fun stream idea.
We blindfold you and you have to meet me.
I don't know.
We're positioned.
One of us is blind.
One of us is me.
One of us is staff, and we all have to fly the stream.
Yeah, one blindfold.
A little bit more to the left, a little bit above.
That's going to be, that's crazy.
I feel like we would just, we would actually dox yourselves
on stream somehow.
Like, I just turned on the webcam.
Which is impressive because there isn't one in here.
Somehow you've managed the impossible.
Yeah.
There's like a top down here.
Oh my God.
There's a camera behind us.
But yes, we are all here.
for an undisclosed work thing.
Wouldn't you like to know?
Very soon.
It would.
We know, but you don't.
Yeah, you'll never know.
We'll know eventually.
You'll know eventually.
You'll know eventually, but that's why we're all here.
They have no idea that.
We didn't find each other randomly on the street.
That would have been funny.
They have no idea we're gonna be the first YouTubers on
Mars.
I mean, what?
Sorry.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I guess someone's not gonna be returning.
You're breaking your NDA over there.
Looks like Rin's never...
It's more of a friend, yeah, right now.
It's just like Rin will never come back to her channel.
She just disappears right after this stream.
He was never seen again after that fateful day.
And then me and Amelie would be like, who's Rin?
It was just a stream with us, too.
And then the government wipes her out of the stream.
That's like a black person being redacted.
They had to redact.
They were like, what are you talking about?
It's always just Amelie and I.
There was no third person.
She was never there.
You could crop her out like we could.
I'm not gonna say why, but that's quite funny considering
something about the thing we're doing.
Wait, where'd she go?
Whoa, Rin!
You guys, imagine that.
She got her.
Guys, they got her.
She's gone now, guys.
I don't know what happened to her.
It's me, the ghost of streams.
They got her.
It's okay.
I'll be Rin.
I'll be really British over here, and I'll be, I'll be Rin
for a moment.
I've never heard that accent in my real life.
No?
She's a voice actor, so she can do it.
What's the craziest accent you've done?
Oh.
Without offending anybody.
One time I got really, I took, I took.
Without offending anybody, what is the craziest accent
you've ever done?
I part took in.
I can't see myself.
That's the main issue.
Yeah, what is it?
One time I was very under the influence and I did an
incredible French accent.
Yeah.
I couldn't believe it.
Went into my booth, recorded some lines doing it.
I was like, sober me, he's not going to remember this.
Wait, for work?
Yeah, well, I was just going to be like, not really sure.
No, no for fun, for fun.
I was home.
I went into my own booth and I recorded it.
And I can never do, I can't do it.
I can't do a French accent.
Like, aw, argh, I can't do it.
But then I got sober the next day and I listened to it and I
was like, that's actually an incredible French accent.
And I can't do it.
You know which goes of crumb off?
I don't know.
Like, try your best.
Oh, did I hear it, Pikmin?
Pikmin.
No, what are you talking about?
I don't know what you're talking about.
Do I sound like Pikmin?
Yeah, does she sound like?
What does Pikmin even sound?
What did I do?
I went, ho, ho, ho, is Pikmin fresh?
I think they're just, I think they're just schizophrenic
right now.
Their voices, the voices, like, the voices in their head are
like Pikmin.
Yeah, that's my crowd coming in.
Yeah, Chad, you know if you guys heard Pikmin, right?
At the end of all of my streams, I have a thing where if you
type Pikmin in the chat, it just plays the Pikmin.
That's cute.
So you just get a horde of people raging and say, well, it's
unfortunate for me and my faff.
Like, were you guys playing Pikmin?
You have no idea.
That's your like, that's your obsession, right, Pikmin?
That's all I know.
Do you have like a lot of Pikmin merch?
How much have you spent on Pikmin?
You know they just released some new ones recently?
It's, did you know that?
I've seen like the Hot Topic Pikmin drop.
Yeah, but do you see like the lottery Pikmin?
The lottery Pikmin?
The one, the gotcha lottery Pikmin.
Oh god.
Oh no.
Forget cute gotcha girls introducing gotcha Pikmin.
To me, just tall.
They can gotcha anything, to be fair.
They can and they will.
Everything is gotcha now.
That little surge of dopamine.
I'm just like, ooh.
I just needed to keep going.
Amblin.
Oh, yeah.
By the way, Amalie has met a lot of famous people.
I can't wait.
All right.
What a segue.
No, I wanted to tell that story.
That's a crazy.
She's never told this story.
You've never heard this story, but yeah.
I'm oh no talking about it last night like yeah like the
most famous person you run into yeah like because like her
friend and my mom yeah yeah my friend my mom your mom's a
friend you know I know it was it was many years ago and I've
never told chat and I actually feel really bad about it but
like it was such a cool thing that I didn't want to talk
about it because like talking about it felt less cool but
then like you know what you know like keeping a secret felt
cooler you know but that's so cool I was like I would tell
that shit I would be like gosh you know I met because I was
like bro, that's fucking insane.
Why would you, I would fucking brag that shit everywhere.
Yeah, I would be like, I met this guy.
I was like, I never met him before.
Oh, that's so cool.
She's, I mean, it was cool.
It was so cool.
You can show it written before.
I will, I will.
I'm gonna show.
Yeah, you're gonna be like, what the, you might not actually
recognize.
I'm gonna have to sell this.
You might actually recognize this because like, I don't
recognize a lot of people to be fed.
That's true, because like when I saw it, I was just like,
well, he just looks like a regular guy.
Yes, yes, yes.
But like, he just looks like a dad.
to be fair a lot of people just look like regular guys yeah
yeah it's because like if you have the confidence to be a
regular guy you will look like a regular guy let me see it
was 2000 it was 2023 or 2022 and I could never remember it
was 15 years ago it was a million years ago but pretty much
I was at I was at anime expo and I got a text from a contact
of mine being like hey I have a celebrity that would love to
meet you.
Are you around?
And I was like, uh, yeah.
Can, may I, madam, may I ask who it is?
And they're like, oh, it's, it's Shannon Tatum and his
daughter.
And I was like, Shannon, Shannon Tatum.
It was like, uh, yeah, tell me where to be and when to be
there.
And my mom was actually with me at Anime Expo because she's
helping me like doing the autograph signing.
So like, I turned to her and they were like, what?
What?
I know, I know.
Damn it!
Magic Mike?
I'm about to make a name for myself.
Oh, yeah.
It's now a good time to say that I don't know anything about
this man.
Like, I've heard the name.
No.
I've never heard Jump Street or...
Have you ever seen Magic Mike?
I've never seen a movie before.
You never seen Magic Mike?
You've never seen...
No, she's never seen a movie.
Oh, it's a single movie?
Yeah, I feel like the single movie is a bigger revelation.
You haven't seen Utopia?
You've never...
No.
Why don't you watch movies?
It's like, look, it's...
restricted it's a possible failing of mine we like none she
needs to watch magic mike at least i guess i know jump
street she needs to i guess i know what we're doing this
evening yeah no i i would suggest jump straight over magic
mike this this poster doesn't ring a bell it's like it's
sexy guys double my accent why is he doing that it's because
they're strippers they're male strippers yeah yeah oh
anyways anyways so about this convention i turned to my mom
and i go do you wait for you here.
And I was like, oh, okay, I guess I'll go alone.
And so I got to meet him and his daughter.
They were so, so sweet.
He was literally just dressed as like a dad.
Like just John somebody.
I love this story was like, I went to meet when he was
complete asshole.
No, so sweet.
He was like a huge fan.
Him and his daughter was a huge fan.
Oh, yeah.
They're just huge fans.
Yeah, I was like, Chad Tatum likes one piece.
I was so surprised.
Like, because like, they were apparently a one piece fans
and they liked her covers, her one piece covers.
So they Really, really what did it mean?
It was really cute.
Yeah, they were asking all these questions about voice
acting and then later down the line, he's in the Demon
Slayer movie he got cast and he brought his daughter to the
red carpet.
I saw photos of them and I was like, yay, full circle.
It was so cute.
Yeah.
But yeah, after I met him, we got a photo and I went back to
my mom.
I left her at Starbucks and I was like, hey mom, look, we
got a photo.
And she looked at the photo and she went, Magic Mike!
Because we all know what the target demographic was for
Magic Mike.
Yeah, Mom!
His name's Shannon did.
Like, yeah, you belays the...
She's like, I didn't know you were gonna go meet Magic Mike.
She thought she was some loser.
Yeah, she didn't know who I was talking about.
She thought I was like, oh, if it's a celebrity who's a fan
of my daughter.
Who's here?
It's Jerry from Down the Butchers.
Yeah, she's just like, well, if it's a celebrity who's a fan
of my daughter, and he must be like a loser or something.
Oh my God.
He must not be that famous.
She's like, you go talk to them, Amanda.
You go ahead.
You go ask John, kid.
Just another, you guys are just like, yeah, it must be
another nerd.
It's like my daughter.
Look at all this weird cultural movie, like which movie does
she like to tell to you, Like you- No, but now you got to
leave Chanda Tatum.
Your mom did it.
I know, so true.
It was an important lesson that day about humility.
Yeah, you should always say yes if you get invited.
Always just go.
Just go.
You might not know who it is.
Who is that?
Yeah, yeah.
Chanda Tatum, I wonder what movie he's from.
Yeah.
Oh, Jump Street, Magic Mike.
She'd be like, Magic Mike!
It was the way she screamed Magic Mike in the middle of this
Starbucks.
Magic Mike!
I think it was so cool that his daughter was cosplaying too.
But I saw the cosplay and it was amazing.
Yeah, yeah.
It was really, really cute.
Yeah, it was so good.
She wasn't cosplaying One Piece.
She was like cosplaying was Furen?
It was Furen.
Yeah, Furen.
Oh, I say good.
It was really, they were so sweet though.
Yeah, the reason I didn't post like a photo or talk about it
is because like she was quite young and I don't want to like
post someone else's kid but since they went to the red
carpet and stuff together and like just photos of them yeah
and we're just talking about it yeah oh my god oh my god we
really want to talk about your friends don't don't oh my god
like can we get her in here and talk about it that story was
crazy though it was pretty crazy wait have you guys ever met
anyone famous no like I mean Kenny Omega is the most famous
guy oh wait who's that he's like a really big wrestler yeah
she's like super it was because i was at capcom but it's
literally like this year so it's because i was at capcom cup
which is like um and he's a huge street fighter like a
fighting game player oh and they hired him to cosplay as
well as host one of your characters so then i didn't know
who kenny omega was like you know like your mom was like
who's that guy i was like i didn't really know who he was um
so the staff was like do you want to meet kenny omega like
because he's here and i was just like oh my god who is he
like i was like i don't know ask questions who learned from
momaly yeah at first i was like it's gonna be so awkward i
don't know who he is i'm gonna be so embarrassed because you
would think i know him and i was just like i don't know what
you are except you're a wrestler like and then so at first i
was like no it's all right and then i wikipedia him like and
i google and i'm being like oh my god this guy is you're all
right i was like i might as well meet him just just to be
like i met him you know so now i was like later i was like,
yeah, I'm down to meet Kenny Omega because I was like, I was
like, fuck it, take the shot, you know?
Might as well.
Just might as well, like, he's here and then it's like gonna
happen again.
He was super chill and like we talked about VTubers and
stuff, like because he was like wrestling sort of like
VTubing.
Oh, of course, yeah.
Cause he's like, oh yeah, I knew about VTubing, but like I
never really like looked much into it.
Wait, I love when they know about VTubing, I'm like, good.
Yeah, because I know KV.
He's lived in Japan for like at least 10 years.
Oh, cool.
Yeah, because he's like, his wrestling moves are inspired by
Japanese anime and like Japanese culture.
and stuff and then like you know we followed each other back
and then like it was really cool youtubers at anime yeah and
it was so cool just hanging out with because we would hang
out in his dressing room and wait that's so cool yeah like
like just hang out and then we were just like because he
loves street fighter so he was like playing street fighter
against like some of my teammates and stuff yeah it was just
really cool to just like learn like just you know meet him
and hang out with him but he's a really cool guy guys i know
super cool i i love when like you meet a a celeb and like
they're actually really cool and sweet and you're like yay
like you can meet your heroes.
Sometimes, not all the time.
What about you?
What's your most famous person?
Oh, God, mine's really, mine's really underwhelming in
comparison.
No, no.
I have a friend who I hang out with sometimes, and he's like
a pretty big streamer, and he shows his face, and every now
and then when we're out together, he will get recognized,
and I have to sit back and be like, no one knows who I am.
They don't know I'm a YouTuber.
But who's the streamer?
His name's Carty Game.
do you guys why do you guys even mean like oh wouldn't you
like to know yes yeah and would love to know i mean amelie
and i told you as how we've been all right when we cut the
cameras we're gonna find out oh lord i will say i run into a
lot of celebrities at like conventions and places because
like yeah it's la too well la as well but mostly conventions
like i'll just be like going to the bathroom or like being
like in the green room or something and i'll just like into
someone and i'll be like oh oh hi no nice to me have a good
okay bye like oh god i think the worst one was who plays the
hulk in the in the room oh wait i said bruce batter no not
bruce um bruce batter bruce banner what's his name oh man um
i i forget his name but he was very sweet i don't remember
but i i just know mark ruffalo yeah yeah thanks chat i was
in a random hallway at a convention and I was it was like a
dressing room like with just one bathroom and no one was
supposed to be in there and so I went to go like open the
door and like you know like that moment like when you go to
open door but the door opens yeah and like we bumped into
each other and I like looked up and I was like oh so sorry
and in my brain I was like and the sirens were getting
louder I was like that's Mark Ruffalo and I was like oh so
sorry like oh have a good one he was like yeah you too and I
was like yeah yeah fine like I was so
I closed the door and I could see myself in the mirror and
I'm like damn I'm a good actor like I was so so cool yeah
you know like I was so cool I didn't have a nervous
breakdown in front of I'm sure there was like one frame of
my eyes flashing with fear just a single frame we're still
not coming to the MCU she said we could talk about her story
oh yeah Get her in here.
Just come in here.
Come here and tell your story.
This is Amelie's mom, by the way.
It is Amelie's.
You just know so many of them.
She's their second mom.
You've got your three separate mothers for you.
This is their second mom.
I mean, happy for you, really.
I am.
I'm not surprised.
Yeah.
Hi, Mom.
Not mom.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, Amelie's mom.
It's not momily.
It's not.
Oh, talk through the- Oh, my God.
Yeah, you could be me.
Oh, yeah.
Is this my YouTuber, David?
Yeah, this is your...
Yeah, can you do your VTU just drop?
Can you just sit down and say, hi, I'm Doki Bird?
Hi, hi, I'm Doki Bird.
Is this how you do it?
Is this how that VTU video happens?
You're doing great, sweaty.
You can see her here, like, she like, well, Nat, like, if
you raise your eyebrows, she'll raise your hands.
We're ever done.
We're witnessing discovery in real time.
Oh my God.
You just like...
Also, it's funny, you can tell a girl who's white.
too because the eyes go so wide.
I'm like, I'm dead.
Whoa.
No, it's always like that whenever I swap with someone and
then they're like, wow.
You're now experiencing, like, this is a formative
experience for literally every VTuber, the first time that
they get like into a bottle.
Wow, it's just like me.
You're just like me.
Wow, this is really fun.
Okay, guys, sorry, Doki Bird's gone.
It's just me now.
I'm right here.
No, she's gone.
Sometimes I can still hear her.
There's a bird here.
Wow, this is fun.
I see why you guys do this.
You're never getting rid of me now.
I like how it looks like you're about to put your arms up,
like we're gonna go for the hands.
Like, is this?
We do not have hand tracking.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's only body and face.
I did just throw my hands in the air, like I just don't
care.
It's like you're on a VTuber roller coaster.
You're like, wee!
The camera's here.
Oh my God.
Okay.
So if you look at that.
Yeah, we could actually angle it higher.
When will my reflection show who I truly am?
Like, oh my gosh, she follows me.
She follows me.
I sit on it down.
Oh my God, this is the best day of my life.
Oh, it's the best day of my life.
Why did I come in here?
Oh, you were gonna tell us a story.
Why did you tell me?
Wait a second.
You're like, I'll say I was here for some reason.
What was it again?
No, just this.
Okay, so wait, which story am I telling?
The, my winter soldier story.
Yeah, your winter soldier.
winter so yes there we go also i'm mad that i learned this
for the very first time last night i didn't know that i
never told you also we just told my my story with shannon
tatum so we have a gambit story and we have a bucky story
what other cats and you have the hulk and i said that story
too i know we're getting the avengers i was listening um
okay so i'll keep it kind of short so many years ago um i
was in la and i was um like just going to back and forth
from like work to meeting friends and whatever.
And I ran into Sebastian Stan twice in two different places
in LA, like three hours, four hours apart.
And I was like, that's weird.
And so me being full of the audacity of an early 20
something, um, I went home and I was like, you know what?
Okay.
I'm going to change clothes.
I'm going to like put on a little bit of makeup.
I'm going to go back to where I last saw him.
And if he's still there, I'm going to take it as a sign and
I'm going to just say hi.
And so by the way, the story, came up when i was asking like
who is the most famous person he's actually ever met and she
was like i almost dated sebastian's dad like what just drops
this nuclear bomb i was like what and i know you for many
years and i've never heard this the winter soldier stopped
you yeah well i guess we're about to find out well i i'll
tell you um i mean i guess the the punchline of the story is
i got ghosted by the winter soldier what's wrong with him
okay So you're such a catch, though.
He's lost.
Yeah.
Men are nothing, girl.
Yes.
Men are nothing.
Well, okay, I gotta say, he was very nice and he was so
charming.
This man was smooth as butter.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I drive, I go home, I drive all the way back, and it's
like a 30-minute drive home and a 30-minute drive back.
So it's like an hour has elapsed and I was like, surely not.
So I pull up, I park my car, and again, I'm like, if he's
there, it's meant to be, I'll say hi.
his keys.
And so he had been delayed like five minutes.
And if the valet had not lost his keys, I would have met
him.
I mean, I would have missed him.
So he's standing outside this place.
And so I walk up and again, just full of the audacity, I
walk right up to him and I was like, hi, I've seen you twice
today.
And I felt like it was a sign.
And I wanted to say hello, fully expecting this man to be
like, who are you?
Get away from me.
Okay, great.
But instead, instead, he's like, oh, really?
Where?
And I was like, oh, you know, I saw you here.
And then I saw you there.
And then I thought, you know, just thinking about it and I
was thinking like that's really weird and then I thought
well maybe it's a sign I should come say hi and this man is
like well maybe we should have a drink about it oh yeah I'm
standing there being like yeah yeah all right sure sure mr.
Bucky Barnes sir and then he takes my phone and puts his
number in my phone and it's like so that's me text me so I
have your number not like oh give me your number and I'll
call you know what No, he put his number in my phone.
Smooth, smooth.
Very smooth.
Yeah, very smooth.
So we stood there talking for a little bit and then we
texted for a little bit and then he was like, I have to go
back to New York earlier than expected.
And I was like, yeah, okay.
And so he went back to New York and then like three weeks
later I got a text.
He was like, I'm back in LA.
I was like, oh, okay.
And then the end of the story as well.
He did.
So the end of the story.
This was post-winter soldier, by the way.
I'm pretty sure it was post-winter soldier pre-Civil War.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I don't fully remember when this was.
She remembers her.
He remembers.
So he does.
And so I, I, I, he was in a restaurant where my friend
worked and again, full of the audacity, I went to the
restaurant to like quote unquote visit my friend.
And then when I walked in, I was like, this is weird.
I'm not going to like go up.
He saw me from across the restaurant and I suddenly get a
text from him that says, nice dress.
And I was like, ooh.
But unfortunately, disappointingly, after that, he ghosted
me and I never heard from him again.
He did come up and he like talked to me at the restaurant
and we were like, oh, you don't fancy seeing you here.
But perhaps he'll see this stream.
She still has his phone number.
I still have a job.
We can show this.
She like showed the number to us.
We're like, Sebastian's dad?
Maybe he's a V-tuber fan.
Who knows?
So the epilogue to this story is that a little while later,
he was at an event for another movie that he did.
And my friend who speaks Romanian.
is Romanian, went to the event and she talked to him
afterwards and because they were speaking Romanian to each
other, some fans started videoing because like, ooh,
Sebastian's fan, Sebastian's fan speaking Romanian.
And in the video, it exists online somewhere.
You can hear her say in Romanian, you actually know my
friend Jennifer Roberts.
Hi, that's my name.
Hello.
And... His name is Jennifer Roberts.
You can't say that.
No, no.
Okay.
I'm a stranger.
I'm an IRL friend of So I exist.
She's a real person.
And so, I mean, I also- See, it's not my mom!
My full name.
Your mom is too.
It's not my mom.
It's too.
But then, yeah, so then you can hear Sebastian be like, he
like put on this like furrowed brow face and he was like,
Jennifer Roberts.
Oh yeah, I remember that.
Oh, that's good.
And I was like, oh, you little goblin.
You know me.
You know my name.
You said I had a nice dress.
That's my story.
I'll give you Doki Bird back now.
The thing was, he was having dinner with fucking Tom Brady.
Oh, he was.
He was having dinner with Tom Brady at the time.
Yeah, and she's so casual.
Tom Brady to you and talk to you.
We did.
Goodness.
Well, thank you, Chet, for letting me hijack the movie's
model.
Congratulations on your debut.
Yeah.
Congratulations.
We're V-Tubers.
It was so much fun.
Oh, my friends will be V-Tubers eventually.
It's my evil plan.
You've heard this so much fun.
Thank you.
I love you.
So yeah, that was the Sebastian Stan story.
And I really...
And for our next guest, we will be having Sebastian Stan.
For our next guest, we're going to call Sebastian Stan and
see if he remembers Jennifer Roberts.
We have stories of the other Avengers now.
We need like an Iron Man story.
Yeah, but you're literally like in LA.
You get to have that opportunity.
Who's coming to Canada?
I'm not going to lie.
Who's coming to you?
I don't think anyone's ever.
Yeah, that's a great point.
Yeah.
No one wants to come to the UK.
You never know.
Yeah, you never know.
I think you guys just have to come to LA.
Yeah, I have to come to LA to walk around.
I recognize no one ever, so I'll be out with friends.
And they're like, that's so and so.
And I'll be like, who, who, where?
Like, I literally don't know.
That is a white man wearing a t-shirt.
Like are you sure?
Yeah, I like how it's like we actually have him right here
in the back.
We're actually having her.
Thomas!
We could get the voice actor, yeah.
We could.
You want to meet Jennifer Roberts?
Unfortunately, Jennifer Roberts is married.
Unfortunately, she had a, she had like a catch.
She heard her husband, she was telling us was, what was it,
the casting for League of Legends?
Which is really cool.
So like, that is like the voice caster, right?
Oh, do you think he could, do you think he could get us in
there?
Perhaps a tour of the, of the, the, the.
Oh, like in LA.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, don't worry, don't worry.
How could we use this post instead of possibly information
for our own post again?
Now that we are all friends of Jennifer Roberts, we could
ask each other, of course.
Yeah, yeah, all of us.
Hey, let me know when you're in LA.
Yeah, and then we can, like, anime expo.
Yeah, and be like, hey, you want to cast us through the
League of Legends?
We can all play the same character.
We can be three little boogie monsters together.
If they have any new character.
No, I'm thinking like a server or something.
It's got three heads, so it needs three different voices.
shuts up because there's three girls talking over each
other.
Yeah.
I think we'd be the most bad character in the movie because
that happened.
I don't want to deal with this.
Please do not play him.
But if it was like a server that like just said like, get
off the game, like log out.
Like delete this uninstall.
Parasocial.
You need to log out.
Jennifer Roberts.
Gigi no heels.
Like it was just like saying like a moral and gamer.
We can't be an arcane guys.
We can't be in the new spin-off.
Imagine that.
Arcane 2.
We now know the husband of voicecaster of League of Legends,
guys.
Nepotism?
It's not nepotism.
Guys, no, we're talented.
We earned our place.
It's not nepotism if you're talented.
I'm wearing my watch.
I just got like a sound alert because it's so bloody noisy.
The sound levels have increased to 90 decibels.
We're not really hearing this now.
We're not drunk, by the way.
Unfortunately, we are drinking watermelon juice.
It's actually so delicious.
I've been chugging.
Do I open it?
I haven't started on mine.
It's good.
I completely forgot.
Come here, baby girl.
I'll open it for you.
Guys, what if they spiked our watermelon juice?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, is this alcoholic?
No, it's not.
I don't think they would give it is not.
I like how it's called FOMO if you're missing out.
That's really cute.
That's cute.
Because you guys have FOMO because you don't know what we're
doing.
Yeah, you don't know what we're doing here.
Enjoy not knowing while it lasts.
Once you know you can never go back.
I mean, it won't be soon.
You won't be waiting too long, guys.
Don't worry.
It's not too long.
What other cryptic hints can we give?
It's the three of us.
We could say, could we say there could have been four of us?
There could have been.
Or maybe there still could be.
There could be.
Who's the missing member?
Tony's still.
Oh, he's wobbly.
No.
Jennifer Roberts.
Holy shit.
Jennifer.
It's actually Winter Soldier.
It's us three and Winter Soldier.
And Sebastian's dad.
We couldn't get him today, so we got the next best thing.
I'm going to post in the movies.
The next best thing, the girl that she almost dated.
Yeah, yeah.
So funny.
Again.
Goku.
I wonder, though.
I wonder what it could be.
Oh my gosh.
It's exciting, though.
Yeah, it's really cool.
You guys are going to see it and do like the Spider-Man meme
and be like, they were talking we should say it's not a
vtuber agency just so people yeah it's not it's not a vtuber
agency we're not starting a new vtuber company don't worry
don't worry the manager Jennifer Roberts I mean less a
manager and more of a wrangler recently I feel yeah we're
all being wrangled that's true that's true also she she has
a lot of cool experiences oh yeah Yeah, Jenna's really cool.
Yeah, I was just like, what?
She would make a really good frame her because she just has
so many tales.
I was so interested.
I was like, your life is much more interesting than mine.
Yeah, I was just like, oh my God.
And she's so humble.
I feel like she walked in before I died.
You are.
She's like, yeah, I served water for Keanu Reeves.
And I was like, what?
You fucking met Keanu Reeves?
The lore drops are crazy.
I'm not going to lie.
Genuinely, I'd love to hear what people think this is.
We can't conform with denial either way.
Yeah, we can't conform with denial, but what do you guys
think?
V-tube away, we have a union.
Oh God, I thought, oh God.
Yeah, we're unionizing right now.
We're creating a union, guys.
I won't pay time off.
A crypto.
Someone's like, every celebrity exists to be a cameo in her
life.
That's good.
The actual main character.
The Jennifer Roberts show.
Actually, like, writing V-tube or Laura around, that would
be pretty crazy.
And every famous person is just a cameo.
It's not about what you know, it's about who you know, it's
about literally everyone.
Oh, yeah, we're going to be in League of Legends.
We're going to be in League, guys.
Talking about voice acting, now that you put me on the spot,
I'm going to put you two on the spot.
Oh, yeah.
We're talking about doing some voice impressions.
Yeah, because we're like, what do we do on stream?
But we were just like, gapping.
You had a good one.
Which one?
Didn't you have one?
No.
No?
You did.
Who was it?
Red, help me!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, Red had a really good one.
Oh, what was yours?
Was this the Victorian orphan voice?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, the little Victorian boy.
Ahem.
People say I'm not a real Victorian orphan, just because my
mum and dad are the king and the king and queen.
Little boy, go into the chimney sweep right now.
Hey, sir, I want to stop eating cold.
Those chimneys aren't going to sweep itself.
Can I have a Tesco meal deal, please, sir.
I've got to be in League of Legends.
Go back to the factory.
I'm going to tell Jennifer Roberts about this and she's
going to kick your ass.
Can you say, but Papa, I want my battle pass now.
But Papa, I want my fortnight battle pass and my V-box.
And that's it.
That's it.
It's pretty good.
It's all I've got.
I've got that and I've got Big Man.
And that's... Pig Man.
It comes and comes.
I've actually never played Pig Man.
It's time to play Pikmin 4.
It's time for both of you to play Pikmin 4.
The hit game on the Nintendo Switch family of consoles.
I played one.
It's more than me, more than me.
No, I didn't play two because I heard two is really hard
because of the water demon.
The water demon?
There's a water demon.
Is it not like a cute, cozy game?
No, it's not.
What?
The Pikmin fight and the Pikmin die and the Pikmin are
trampled and the Pikmin...
What the fuck?
Okay, when I stream...
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Is that Jennifer Roberts?
Hello!
It's mom 2.0.
It's my other mom.
It's your other mom.
It's us.
Wow.
We can't see what the food is.
Okay, gotcha.
Okay.
It's a hell-less box.
Whoa.
Spaghetti?
Wow.
We're in Italy?
Thank you, Aunt Lily's mama.
Oh my God.
I love hot dogs.
I love, yeah.
I love hot dogs and spaghetti.
Holy shit, jelly donuts.
Oh my God.
My name's so many.
That's great, Jennifer Roberts.
Your entire life.
Jennifer Roberts.
Thanks, Jennifer Roberts.
She's just like, she sounds like, oh, what's her name?
Jennifer, there's another famous celebrity.
There's another famous celebrity that's like something
Roberts.
Jennifer, uh, something Roberts.
Or like Jennifer something.
I'm gonna say Jennifer, because there's lots of Jennifer.
There's lots of Jennifer.
I feel like there's a lot of Roberts and Julie Roberts.
Julie Roberts.
I keep thinking about Julie Roberts.
Oh, yeah, Jennifer, Julie.
Yeah, I keep thinking about Julie Roberts when I say
Jennifer Roberts.
Whoa, whoa.
And they get a mess over here.
What were we talking about before we got her?
Before we got her.
Pickman, pickman.
Oh, so in Pickman.
Voice impressions as well.
Okay, so, well, okay, that's mine.
So obviously Rin can explain Pickman more, but yeah, it's
brutal.
It's very.
Pickman is a game about survival in harsh conditions.
Wait, what?
It's not just like a cute little- No, it's timed.
What?
Oh my God, is it, is it, um, is it a triathlon?
What's your with that?
What's the word?
The pigmen have to like jump.
The pigmen has to jump, swim.
Are you thinking about platformer?
Yeah, platformer.
How did you get to triathlon?
Oh, because she's very much.
I'm really white.
I don't know.
No, because you would see how you're going to watch
triathlon for Olympics.
Oh, yeah.
So basically, pigmen is you have a bunch of pigmen, but some
pigmen can swim.
There's only one pigmen that can swim, which is the blue
pigment, and one pigment that can withstand fire, which is a
red pigment.
and shit like that.
And you have to, there's a lot of, basically the aim is you
got to go gather up a bunch of stuff in a big world and you
are two centimeters tall.
Got it.
And you can die from fire, electricity, or water.
So you do the switch, like do the pigments, like a switch
out?
Yeah, you have to, like, you get to choose how many pigments
you want from each other.
And there are enemies and they will try and kill your
pigments.
So when I straight- Like murder.
Is it platformer?
It's not, no.
Oh, okay.
There's a tiny bit of platforming you before.
It's just the pigments doing the platform.
It's like a real-time strategy thing, but you're like on the
ground.
Yeah, so, but it's time in the case where you have to do all
these missions before X amount of days.
Before the sun goes down, because when the night comes out,
like all the horrible fucking call pops come out.
So the one thing, oh, it's okay, my leg caught it, but okay,
so...
Thank your leg for catching my knife.
Yeah.
So the thing about it is that in Pikmin, when I stream
Pikmin, this is my best thing about Pikmin, is if anyone in
my chat pisses me off, I'd be like, this is you, and I throw
them into the water and let them down.
I'd be like...
Like, I can't work with you anymore.
And then my chat tried to unionize against...
They're like, we want a union.
I was like, who's the union leader?
I'll be like, oh, Jacob?
All right, Jacob, off to the water, you go.
Your union's dead.
You choose one and you're like, Like, that's Jacob.
Because you and 10 gifted subs and I let him live.
Yeah.
That's my fucking ransom.
Yeah, I'll just be like, who's your union leader?
Jacob?
All right, Jacob.
the more we know how to swim, Jacob.
Tell me an Avengers story or die.
Which pigment is Jennifer Roberts?
Yeah, which pigment is Jennifer Roberts, the one that can't
swim?
No, I'm a leaf!
I was going to turn into an ASMR stream because we're all
eating a meal.
Our colorless blocks of food.
Yeah, our colorless, our spaghetti and hot dogs.
We're actually still on the airplane.
Yeah, we're actually swimming from the plane right now.
private jet i know it's one of taylor swiss private jets
that she loaned us because jennifer robbins knew her i was
gonna say yeah honestly you got here before i thought i was
chewing yeah jen jenna really hooked us up with uh yeah with
t swift's uh pj yeah she knows everybody guys it's crazy i
can't believe she knows she's good friends with taylor with
also i should have asked as well before we like when we
first started like how's the volume guy oh yeah it's been
how's the volume minutes yeah it's been 40 minutes but how's
the echo now's the non-stream echo how do you get food
delivered to a private jet we have a private chef on the
food plane yeah it's actually another plane that pulls up
it's actually bucky barnes
As scuffed as it can be, it can be that bad.
It's nice and loud.
We've seen one.
Bad, but we, I'm so curious when we rewatched the vlog.
I know, it's gonna be horrible.
Oh my God, we sound like we're in as much as we can.
25 minutes had echo, so.
It was not 25 minutes.
I was dying in all the comments going, it's Amma's fault.
Oh, sure.
Amma's fault.
Yeah, okay, about as good as can be, Porn and Huff.
That's my sound, Dad.
There's a sound guy going about as good as we expected.
Yeah.
You know, like, we're trying.
They call in an audio engineer, Jennifer Roberts.
Hey, Jen.
She can do everything.
She wears a lot of hats.
Oh, my God.
She can do it all.
Yes, girl.
Go, girl.
I'm like thinking, when we were talking about, like, the
most famous person we've ever met, like, have I ever met
someone more famous than Kenny Omega?
I'm like, Jennifer Roberts.
She knows she's Jennifer Roberts.
Honestly, I, yeah, meeting Jennifer Roberts, that was.
That's the most famous person I've ever.
It was Kenny Omega, and then it became Jennifer.
See, you don't need to be famous, but if you know everyone,
then everyone knows you.
So that makes you a celebrity.
Like, she's like, mitosis, meiosis, or something.
Yeah, just by association.
She has, like, just really cool, like, stats, because she's
just met so many people.
Biologist in me has to tell you that it is mitosis.
Mitosis is a different form.
Someone had John Cena.
Damn.
That's cool.
How were you able to see him?
Yeah, I was gonna say, how would you see him?
Actually, I do have another funny story about someone
famous.
I was at a convention and an agent came up to me and they
were like, hey, I'm the agent for Charles Martinet, who is
the voice of Mario and Luigi.
Oh, that's cool.
Hey, his kids are here and they're really big fans of you.
Would be okay if they came by and said hi?
And I was like, oh my God, of course, yeah.
Charles came with them.
And it was just so, it was just so crazy because I was like,
sir, I should be in your line.
Like, this is wrong.
Like, this shit is not Mario.
Mario.
Yeah, literally.
And it was so sweet.
I signed a bunch of stuff for him.
And he was like, and if you want something for me, come by.
And I did.
I was like, can I get something for my cousins?
Like, and he was just, he was like, doing the voice the
whole time.
It was really cool.
Yeah, it was, no, it was just crazy, though.
Because I was like, I don't, I don't feel real being behind
this side of the ground.
You had over the altar ground, and he's like, yeah, yeah,
literally.
I was like, you're in line.
This is crazy.
That's insane.
Wait, some of my chat was like, you once met Post Malone.
I was like, I did not meet Post.
Post Malone really loves Apex.
Wait, really?
Yeah, he's a huge Apex fan.
Oh, yeah, I know this.
Post Malone would host Apex Customs with pro players and
streamers, and I got invited to one of, I think, like, I got
invited to two of them.
And one time, Post Malone spectated me because he died, so
my team killed him.
So people were like, oh my God, Post Malone is watching your
gameplay.
And I was like, no, don't watch my gameplay.
You've seen every great response.
Yeah, I was like, no, don't watch it.
See, again, I know very little of popular culture in
general, so I hear Postman Owen and I'm like, oh, does he
know Postman Pat?
I'll just say he sang the song in this movie, but you don't
watch movies.
I'm telling you to watch some movies.
I haven't seen any films, I've never watched any TV shows.
I've never even listened.
I don't even know what music is.
Oh my God.
No, you do.
You know pigment music.
That's odd.
That's a difference.
Oh, my gosh.
But, yeah, I know there's a lot of music artists are huge.
Oh, wait, lots of music.
Who, what, what?
Which one?
There's so many.
Is that Post Malone's Oshie?
Jokey Bird?
Oh, yeah.
I heard he owns the One Ring for Magic the Gathering.
I heard that.
What?
So, you know about the One Ring card?
It's like a...
You know about it.
I like how you're looking at me because you know that I
don't.
Yeah, because you don't know what it's a TV.
showin so i was like i know she would know it but i was like
about all the pop culture references i'm like do you know
about do you know magic why they need to gather the magic
did they spill it everywhere i remember we were talking
about faker and then apparently when we were talking about
faker's tower you were like is he a wizard or something i
was like that i keep hearing some about to be a wizard.
Yeah, is he a wizard or something?
You know, casting spells from Faker's tower to save off the
knights below.
No, no, no, Faker has his own building and it's called
Faker's Towers, so we were talking about that.
She's like, is he a wizard?
A wizard!
I love Rin, because your reads are so like, I can't tell if
you're like just really comically like inclined, or if you
actually don't, like you actually- I've never done a joke in
my life.
Or like, she's just pretty.
I'm always serious.
I'm serious right now.
No, she's just British.
That's how they all are.
You can never tell if they're...
Yeah, they build me like this in the factory, I'm afraid.
It's like...
I'm watching Taskmaster.
I'm gonna die in seven days.
I feel like we're in...
Have you ever seen Taskmaster?
I feel like I'm in Taskmaster right now.
And she's just...
She's like both of the hosts combined.
Leave the stream without losing your goddamn mind.
The task begins now.
Yeah, she's a silent...
Welcome to your YouTube account 75 times.
Go.
Call in a celebrity as quickly as you put.
Jennifer Roberts!
You're spaghetti!
You're hot dogs!
You clots!
You clumsy fellow!
Jennifer Roberts, we need a tissue!
Can she clean this for me?
Is she housekeeping stuff?
I guess that's how she needs so many selections.
I was actually about to be full anyway, so it's all right.
I didn't want to eat this spaghetti.
It's gone.
Doki has completely spilled all of her food.
All of her food.
We need a few napkins.
We need some.
All I can offer you is this.
Incredible.
That's enough.
Thank you.
Also, could we take this away?
Sorry, thank you.
Thank you so much, Jennifer Roberts.
A dog, I guess.
You really can't have anything nice, can you?
I want to let me know that Doki spilled that all by herself.
I cost fake his boss.
I would like to say that it was, they sabotaged me.
No, no.
so jealous of my pasta so you see it in the food well they
were so jealous yeah i think so thanks mom thank you
amelie's mom yeah what was my name again i think i forgot oh
mama lady mama lee mama lee you've left your unspecified uh
utensil in the florida where is it we'll get it later my my
spork know what's the truth and what's that my chopped stick
oh what were you talking about i already forgot during the
whole you smelling my rice and curry british people all
british people i'm sorry they're just like that i'm sorry i
you can never know i'm sorry you know just getting some
apologies ever ever since he is mama lee single yes she is
the one
Which one?
She actually is.
Just one.
Is she British?
Is she?
No, thank God for that.
Which mom?
Oh.
I've lost track of which mom.
Not that, my actual mom.
Not that mom.
That's right.
I have so many moms.
Yeah, I've lost track of which mom it is.
Happy Pride months?
Hey!
Yeah, for Roberts to single.
Unfortunately, her husband is, like we said, the voice.
Very cool.
The castor, voice castor of League of Legends.
So you might not be able to compare.
You know, shoot your shot.
Good luck.
Don't expect anything.
I don't know if you can outdo that, being the voicecaster of
League of Legends.
She's taken.
Well, it's been fun.
We can't say what we've been doing, unfortunately, because
everything's sitting in like a featureless room for 18 hours
a day.
We've been locked up in a room.
Actually, we don't even know what we're doing, actually.
I couldn't even tell you.
I'm just kidding.
I mean, you say that.
We couldn't even tell you.
Oh, we met Snabby.
Oh, of course.
I mean, who's Snabby?
Who's Snabby?
That's what the...
You can find out when you meet him again or have Snabby.
See, you're right?
I'm a real one.
I know who Snabby is.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm a real one.
She was like, she's been...
I know where my friends are.
The fact that Rin was holding this...
I thought it was like a Pikmin character.
It might as well be.
Yeah, close enough.
I was like, this plushie the entire day yesterday.
You're like, who's Snubby?
Who the fuck is?
We would be like sitting down and I like come out to chair
and put him on it.
Yeah, but I hear his name.
No, she has said her name.
She has said his name.
He's like, I haven't heard it.
I have Snubby here.
Anyways, nice to meet you, Snubby.
It's a pleasure to formally meet you.
Have you met Jennifer Roberts?
I can't believe it.
I feel like Jennifer would remember Snubby's name.
Oh, damn it.
I think she already has.
Well, she's listening to the stream now, so we can't test
her.
before the delay hit.
Fake fat.
I know, I'm a Lisa fake fat.
That's fucked.
It's literally in my channel name.
How could you?
Basic market research.
You see, I'm a good, I'm a good.
When I left my agency, I used to, so I used to be like in an
agency.
I'm indie now.
Yeah, that's why we're not starting a YouTuber agency
because she didn't want to.
None of us wanted to.
Yeah, we only got vetoed by Rin.
We want to say something somehow.
We should start and then we all came here.
we're like going to attempt that we're starting V2 Regency
and then we actually came here to ask for like startup
capital.
Yeah, yeah.
And then Ren was like, guys, I don't think we should do it,
guys.
And now we're stuck here.
Now we just can't leave until we come to an agreement.
Yeah, yeah.
We're like, it's like we're in court right now in the jury.
No, everyone has to vote for you.
I'm fighting for custody of Snebby.
Oh, no.
But yeah, I used to be in an agency and we had the kind of
format for our channel names of like, you know, Rin Penrose
channel, like company name, or whatever.
And then I left the agency and I had to take the company
name out of my YouTube channel name.
And I was like, oh, it feels a bit weird if it's just
Rinpenro's, I'm not used to it being that short.
Uh, uh, I can fix this.
Uh, Rinpenro's channel and Stebby, he's part of the team now
too.
Yeah, that's your whole, and then now she's like the mascot
of the channel.
I'm the mascot, he's the one who actually does all the
world.
Oh, that's true, he's the CEO.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, you just, you know, it just recreates.
The only good V-tube agency in the front line has a snail.
Finally, guys, we did it, we solved the impossible problem.
It just has to be run by, a fucking stealth listen he's got
like pure intent in his heart which you can't say very
intelligent so yeah so rin doesn't want to leave snabby so
now like you know we just got out of a meeting for like a
loan um and then so i don't know what to do he's running the
meetings with the shareholders he's wearing like a tie so
you know he's better dressed he owns 80 of the company yeah
yeah we're like wait a minute i thought i thought that was
gonna be a fair deal wait a minute these splits don't make
sense nothing is not biased yeah and then yeah and then Rin
gets like the next 9% and then yeah 90% of the profits 9% of
the responsibility that's the real CEO right there oh that's
a real CEO she's some to think maybe this is commentary on
the state of the industry that's on for legal reasons I will
not agree or disagree confirm or deny for legal reasons i
like gladly well i've got very strong opinions weird to see
what on my channel i just realized on my channel yeah you're
taking all the blame yeah i'm taking all i mean i'm yeah is
it whatever i want doki's phone number is three doki's
password is three doki's credit card number three she saw me
she saw me input i showed her she saw all of your passwords
on a discord server yeah and i was like wait i'm sorry He
spoiled them.
Godwoman.
Yeah, it's like.
On a Discord server?
Did she not save?
She had it open.
It was on her monitor, so.
That's not safe at all.
Why are you doing that?
Not all the passwords.
Even I know that's not safe.
At least I'm out of like, Braille, we'll make them walk.
It's not all the passwords, guys.
I told Chad that I have all my passwords in a book, and they
went, that's so unsafe.
And I was like, well.
Listen, if the hacker is inside your house, you have bigger
problems.
That's so true.
That's true.
I feel like, why would they go for the book first?
No, like, while I look at you through my drawers, I'm like,
you must be here.
Where's her diary?
I want to read her diary real quick.
I want to know what's going on in life of Amelie.
Not the book.
Honestly, all those passwords are old because I forget my
passwords all the time.
Oh, yeah, you said that every time you log into something,
you reset your password.
Every time I log in, I reset, and then I let my phone choose
the password, which is just like gobbledygook.
It's in God's hands now.
Yeah, and then obviously that doesn't get saved anywhere, so
it doesn't matter.
and then I change it again next week.
So I'm actually the safest person alive.
No one's hacking into my shit.
It doesn't protect you from the scuff, though.
It doesn't protect me from me, but it protects me from
everybody else, and that's all that really matters.
If you don't know what's going on, nobody knows what's going
on.
If I can't get in, no one can.
That's all that means.
I just keep all my passwords in my manager's head, so if
anything happens to her, I'm done for.
Yeah, what if she gets kidnapped?
Oh, it's more when than if.
Like, who's going to, how are you going to log on to your
YouTube channel?
That's how we're going to get 100% of the company.
Also, the fact that your manager is kidnapped, but also, how
would you log into your YouTube channel?
I have priorities here.
Like, oh no, something horrible has happened to Zoe.
But I do need to do that as well.
But I have a stream in 10 minutes.
We'll get to that when we get to that.
I got, I can't miss a stream.
We're playing Pikmin today.
I'm sorry, Zoe.
So you get it.
Well, maybe for Galton.
Who knows?
Yeah.
But it's been fun hanging out, guys.
It's been really fun.
In that room that we were locked in for the last couple of
days.
It's been pretty fun.
I haven't seen the sun in weeks.
That might be a me problem.
Yeah, we got to hang out a lot.
We're going to hang out after...
We're going shopping after this.
We're going to the undisclosed store to buy undisclosed
products.
We're going to Universal.
Oh, my God.
Women do be shopping?
I took the biggest bite of pasta.
Oh, I can't get rid of this.
Yeah, we're going to Universal, we're at Disneyland, we're
going to go shopping.
At the same time.
Shopping.
Shopping?
We're going to Wellington Towers somehow.
Yeah, we're going to go to completely different countries.
Was that the Dolby something?
What's her name?
There was an amusement park in America opened by a
celebrity.
Oh, Dolly.
Yeah, we're going to Dolly Parton.
Yeah, we're going to Dolly Parton, too.
We're flying everywhere.
We're going to actually record it all and then just have
black bars over all of our faces.
that so they're in l.a so only 10 of the video can actually
be seen we're going to six flags too it's okay i know we can
get into dollywood because uh jennifer roberts knows her
yeah oh we're going to like neverland is neverland still up
or is that been closed down since neverland you know the
netherlands no netherland neverland neverland park where
michael jackson yeah wait i don't know if that's still
around is that still around god are you older than how do i
don't even know about that.
You're older than me?
What do you mean?
Everybody is old.
No, there's no way anybody can be older than you.
I'm sorry.
Very easily.
Come on, Patricia.
It's been great.
I'm not going to hang out with my friend Jennifer Roberts.
You guys have fun.
I'm sorry.
What do you mean no one can be older than me?
What do you mean?
You're like, I've seen at least one or two, you know?
I can't even run to be president of the United States yet.
Famously, I was born in Victorian times, so...
When I can be, when I can run for president, it's over for
you losers.
You got one more year!
One more year of freedom!
For your first degree.
The coldest freedom?
We're like, execute tokeybird.
We gotta get her out of cast.
Capital punishment's back on the menu!
We're like, extra tech tokeybird to America.
An ex-executor.
Well, should I have said that wrong, kid?
Okay, the snail's gonna be my VP.
We're gonna be fine.
A man we can trust.
But no, I remember in the Michael Jackson land because
Southport made an episode about it.
So that's why I wrote about it.
I thought you just remembered it existed.
No, I just, I remember, I knew it was a real thing because I
remember it from the South Park episode.
Wait, is it still around?
I don't, what the- Please do not play copyrighted material
on this stream.
I won't play it on your speakers.
I'm gonna Google it.
Hey guys, check this out.
Do I have magic mic pulled up once again?
Wait.
I just remember.
I just remember that that's the only reason why.
Juki, are you older than me?
I've just remembered, by the way.
We're coming up on an hour, and the BGM is an hour loop.
Did you remember to loop it?
Because otherwise, we're just going to be inside.
Oh, my God.
There we go.
Is it still around?
Hold on.
Let me.
What the hell was that?
You all hear that?
Bink-been.
What?
That was me, sorry, that was my impression, was it good?
Oh, of course.
Yeah.
Wait, yeah, but is this still around?
It is.
Functioning?
So...
Did it not close it down?
I like how your phone...
I think it's still around.
The phone...
No, not...
No, I meant the amusement park.
My phone's free.
My phone is Emma.
Is Emma Frost?
Yeah, Emma Frost.
Because that's my wife.
That's queen.
My background is Emma Frost.
It's the...
It's the Momo.
Momo, um...
My background is me.
The artist.
She's my queen.
Momo.
Momokie.
She designed a lot of Marvel Rival stuff.
Anyways, I'm addicted to Marvel Rivals.
Anyways, my phone wallpaper is, you'll never guess.
I like how my full wallpaper is literally a picture of me.
It's yourself.
I saw that.
I was like, wow.
Backgrounds are self.
But then also after I unlock it, it's also me.
Every day I look in the mirror, what kind of man do I want
to become?
It's me.
It's yours.
No, mine is.
Mine is snippy.
And then when you unlock it, oh, it's stacked, it's like,
wow, we're like the three horsemen of the apocalypse.
We're going to either frost yourself.
Myself.
I love myself.
The council will decide your fate.
Honestly, no, one of my other backgrounds was myself too.
I had a, I'm not sure how do I get, ooh, oh, that's your
visa.
You guys, I know her last three days.
No, no, no.
Shopping on me.
Uh, no.
Neverland is a 2,700 acre private estate in California.
California is present tense oh yeah but I'm pretty sure he
shut it down after he died I'm pretty sure uh is it still
around wait Neverland Park is still around he did right like
who's funding it because he's dead so yes the physical
estate however the amusement park and zoo were long gone oh
damn it but the estate is still around we could have gone
there in 15 There's a ranch.
Oh, it's a ranch now.
We should go there today, tomorrow.
Yeah, we should.
We should go there yesterday.
We should go there tomorrow.
Hey, Bucky, can you like pull me, put the private chat
around?
Get our security guard to get us to Sycamore Ranch.
Yeah, we're going to go to the, we're going to Neverland
tomorrow, guys.
Hey, Taylor, you mind?
We need the jet for another day.
We need, yeah.
God, the sea tubing stuff goes places you would, don't
expect.
Yeah, we could be anywhere.
stream bin any lag it should be good sorry for a second i
thought you meant quality as in like entertainment value
yeah when would you rate honestly like remember to rate five
stars rate five star we would tap the bell button i've
actually never done an off collab you never did no it's my
first congratulations on this is why i always tell people
you never forget you never forget your first time yeah we
took it off collab virgin yeah off collab genity we did it
what a great great place to start.
Family friendly PG clean.
It is.
It's a problem for them.
If I have PG accepted myself enough, it'll become true.
It's still family friendly if you think about it.
It's about, it's, when you teach, it's educational.
It can't get more family friendly than you guys meeting my
mom.
Yeah, exactly.
It's okay.
Oh my God.
But it's been very exciting meeting.
has been implying that after this, it's just gonna be
completely leaving.
Actually, I'm never gonna talk to you guys ever again after
this.
Actually, sorry, here you guys, I'm so happy you guys
accepted the contract, the, to be on my stream for the Opal
app.
I'm doing like 2.5%.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The NDA, which we've reached 15 times.
Thank you for letting me pay you guys to be on my stream.
Any time, any time.
You know, like those cap- I expect royalties from the app.
Yeah, yeah, no, yeah.
The cameo, I paid for a cameo.
I will accept in sweet treats.
I will accept payment in sweet treats.
love and affection yeah oh my gosh oh yeah also battle can i
see this but i don't know if i can see i can i see this well
if you say it then like yeah yeah i want to say it tape it
i'll tape it okay probably should have figured this out
before no i just thought about it you're getting paid Wait,
you're getting paid?
Jennifer doesn't do this to me.
Can I say this?
Because I want to say I didn't expect, I was not expecting.
Oh, no?
Okay, I can't say it.
Sorry, unfortunately.
No one's allowed to know that I dress like a middle-aged
man.
I mean, what?
What?
Okay, it's our little secret.
I opened up my suitcase, all jorts.
Yeah.
Sorry, you can't know, chap.
She came in with a suit.
It was crazy.
yeah i was confused i thought this was a black tie event
yeah i really love your shrek onesie you want to see my
shirt oh it says i want money i want money this is my
favorite it's actually really good i know can i describe it
yeah yeah no i told them of the shirt oh nice yeah it's cute
yeah it's like a scribbly drawn uh meowth which is so good i
want money yeah so yeah so Say a meowth impression.
I don't know what he sounds like.
I like not me.
I don't necessarily think so.
No, that's more kooky.
No, he's not me.
He's like, meow.
I thought he was more like, I'm walking here.
I don't think he's that.
Yeah, so I wore this shirt.
It's been a while since I've seen it.
Is that in New York?
Is it a New York accent?
New York accent?
Hey.
You remember, he's so long.
Hey, you boys.
Hey, you, Team Rocket.
What's your mash kitchen?
Go Pikachu, use Thunderbolt.
Oh, my gosh.
That's all I've got.
Get into Pokeball!
That's what they're doing to us after the stream wraps.
That's JP Meowth.
I don't remember.
I know like the north, the English, the Meowth, passed away
a couple of years ago.
Oh, goodness.
Yeah, I remember that.
But I don't remember her voice because it was a very iconic
Meowth voice.
There's a lot of things that I'm like, what did that sound
like?
And then I listen to it as an adult and I go, oh my God.
I've ever done those activities where someone gives you a
picture of someone you've never heard the voice of and you
get to make up a voice for it.
small we would have done that today yeah yeah oh that would
have been funny you've done you've done i i haven't done it
but i've seen videos of them doing it and what's a character
you've never okay pick me but she knows it now okay i
haven't known i don't know a lot of uh like older like games
older games okay i'm trying to the palette from pong okay
what okay wait chat These are some characters that I
wouldn't know.
These are some characters that you would think she wouldn't
know.
If it helps you out, my very first video game was Final
Fantasy 10-2.
Not 10, just 10-2.
That was really bad.
And I was so confused.
Me too.
And then, which one?
Hold on.
Why is OBS saying...
Oh, oh, it like DC'd for a little bit.
It's okay, they didn't know.
Are we back?
They don't know.
They're back.
I don't know.
We're back.
Okay, it's okay.
Chat didn't say anything.
Oh, oh, no, it did!
Chat didn't say it!
It's a little notification out the corner of my eye.
We're back.
Sorry, I farted on the computer cables.
It's my bad.
All right, guys.
Give us some things.
Give us some characters.
Some characters.
And then we'll see how close I get.
Yeah, we'll see how close I get.
But you have to tell me if I'm hot or cold.
Okay.
We're going to see something that she could voice.
You have to like direct me through it.
You can direct me like to the correct voice.
Let's see.
There's Crash Bandicoot.
Have you ever heard?
I don't know what that is.
Oh.
Okay.
like oh my god here's holy here he looks wacky look at that
face he is wacky he is wacky yeah uh what are some guys uh
well okay so he loves to say he loves to go give me the
audition side wa-hu he likes to go and yow he just says like
work like he just says sound effect yeah yeah so how many
words you look at him and be like can you give me a
character description just say whoa he's a man in his he's
he's a high pitch he's high he's young he's silly he's high
pitch young he's young yeah young teenager wacky um like you
know like those looney dude you just had that ready to go
wow i don't know okay how about whoa whoa no he's over yeah
whoa is it is it higher
He knows, okay, a little higher, a little higher.
Yahoo!
See, I feel like this is giving more Princess Daisy.
It's off.
Hi, I'm Daisy!
You're not gonna tell me how that was more code, actually.
Let's go!
So he's like, whoa!
Like, whoa!
Yeah, yeah, that's cool.
Do you remember that meme from like ages ago that was like,
whoa.
Yeah, whoa!
No!
That is Crash Bandicoot.
We will play the video for you after the stream.
Okay, moderating.
So like, so like they wouldn't, they wouldn't struck my
channel being like, this video has been struck by the whoa
video.
We, you guys do the impressions.
We did.
We just did.
That was it.
I was pretty close.
I was pretty close then.
But you were like, you were more like, whoa.
I'm trying to be a teenage boy.
You're like, yeah, teenage smoking.
Hurry up!
I smoked 20 cigarettes a day.
I'm a teenage boy.
Okay, guys, you have another character, guys, or another-
Give me a girl, give me a- give me not a man.
Not a man.
Give us a woman character.
Or a female character.
Give us that.
Does she know Goku?
I'm pretty sure you would know Goku.
It's also a man.
Yeah, which is- I voice zero men.
We can always change that.
I mean, oh, wait, I don't- I mean, of course you'll know
Shigo.
Of course you'll know her voice.
It's like a lady talking.
A lot of people are as it turns out.
Yeah.
Don't keep going.
Yeah, I've never heard of that person.
Yeah.
What do you think those people are like?
Rouge the cat, the bat.
Rouge the cat?
The bat.
Yeah.
It's a Sonic character.
Oh my gosh.
So you've never heard her voice.
She was like...
I'm actually not a big Sonic fan, which is really funny
because Sayu got into Sonic and a lot of my chat was like,
aren't she mad?
And I'm like, I actually don't know Sonic.
Oh my God.
She's sexy.
Yes.
Yeah.
Wait, is this a video game?
Wait, maybe I should be.
Maybe I should like Sonic.
Holy shit, wait a second.
I thought Sonic was just all like, men, wait.
I think she like talks like this.
Oh, oh, Sonic.
Wait, that's pretty close.
Oh, too close.
What are some lines?
I mean, you're on the word.
She also just go, whoa.
Yeah, ooh.
Oh my.
It's not bad.
Wait, younger, older?
It's like...
It depends on the...
They got voice now, though, doesn't it?
Yeah, but then it's similar.
It's a similar cadence to it.
Yeah, it's similar to it.
Um, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Give us a line.
What if she just...
Okay, give us a line.
What does she say?
Yeah, what does she...
This is hard.
She's never heard of voice.
I don't know what this game.
Oh, something to say.
Just say gems?
Wow, I sure love gems.
It's so pretty.
Love gems and pearls and diamonds.
Yeah, she's good.
It's like a little too like up and down-ish, but she's like
more...
Wow, I love diamonds.
Diamonds are so nice.
I don't think this guy likes diamonds.
I love latinas.
Okay, that's shadow.
That's shadow.
So, oh, you got it.
That was it.
Wait, yeah, yeah.
Where's that damn fourth chaos emerald?
Wait.
Oh my god, she's never heard of her before.
She's never heard of her.
It's slightly Emma Frost from Marvel Rivals.
Oh my, that's a- It's not couture, darling.
Oh my god.
It's like she's a voice actress or something.
Yeah.
Who would have known?
Wait, wait, wait, I like this.
Oh my god.
That shadow again?
Yo, holy shit.
I love my penis.
I will do one more, guys.
One more for the road.
One more for the rose.
She's sexy!
I'm so much you don't know her.
I'm like, I think I've seen pictures of her, but I didn't
know she's from Sonic.
Yeah, she's, she was, people were really mad because they
took her boobs away during this game.
Honestly, base, honestly fair.
Wait, what does she look like?
What does she look like flat?
She's like, you can, uh...
They like fully took them away?
They like basically made her, made it cover it more.
They sucked them away?
Yeah, yeah, I'm trying to find it.
I just remember them being, so you see, all these pictures
are like, limited time on this uh and you're spending it
just put no boobs in the google search flat okay new new
model no boobs it's a safe search on oh yeah no that's not
it wait before after here so like here it's like oh they
like took away like the they just like gave her a big heart
yeah the bigger hearts like covers it more and we're just
like please take this away from me the kids these I don't
know what we had.
Yeah.
I haven't played.
All right.
One last one.
Josh, I'm pretty sure you know March Simpson.
I didn't think I know March Simpson.
I wanted to take off your jacket.
Did you mean to do that?
Oh, no.
It just falls off.
I was getting hot and bothered.
She's stripping over here.
I was like, oh, my God, that was such a good road to bed.
Bad.
We're on the beach.
We're the gyms.
I stole my collarbones now.
Yeah.
Were you hiding the gyms under your cap?
You can't do this in front of anyone.
that's considered a crime.
Oh, I'm showing my ankles now too, Ren.
Are you embarrassed?
Not the sexy ankles.
I'll never forget I went to like...
No, I showed my ankles to the little boy, the Victorian boy.
He's going to die.
He's going to have a fucking heart attack now.
This is mine, right?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Mine's the one that is fully drunk because I can't say no to
a sweet dream.
Remember, I'm somewhat...
characters.
Come on, do your job.
What are you even useful for?
What are you even here for?
I'm a Pokemon.
You don't know a lot of Pokemon.
I don't know a lot of Pokemon.
Give me a Pokemon that's not in the first gen.
I was going to give you a first gen.
I was going to give you a squirtle.
I could probably do first gen.
I could probably make an educated guess on first gen.
Yeah.
Have you, you know squirtle's voice, right?
Squirtle.
Yeah.
And he's like, yeah.
He's like, yeah.
Of course, mud, you know mud kid.
Oh, mud kid.
Wait, wait, no.
Oh, no!
I used to get the evolved one.
Oh, I was thinking of the guy, the trash man.
The trash?
You thought that kid was the...
Yeah, sorry.
This guy looks like he like...
Oh, she doesn't know.
Mudkip.
Does he say his name?
Yeah.
They all say their name.
Yeah, but some of them say no.
I definitely...
Some of them go, wow!
Like, you know, like, some of them don't say their name.
I definitely know this one because we used to call my
younger brother Mudkip back when he was real small because
he loved this guy.
He looks like a teenager.
So, like, he's a little baby.
He's just a baby.
Look at this dude.
Oh, Munchip.
Munchip.
You got little cheeks.
Does he?
No.
It's like a high pitch.
Munchip.
That's actually pretty close.
It's like, Munchip.
Oh, Munchip.
He's very cute.
He's pretty close.
It's pretty close under fruit.
Yeah, he's like, Munchip.
And when he's angry, Munchip.
Munchip.
Have you, I think they all do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
about doing a Pokemon voice role?
I would love to.
I was Lily in Pokemon Evolutions.
Oh, of course.
But I haven't done an actual Pokemon yet.
I would honestly, hey, John Pokemon, I would love to get in
the booth and go, wow!
Yeah, I feel like that'd be fun.
Just doing random like noises.
I would love that.
Because like they must cast a lot of people.
I want to voice one of the gods though so I could be like,
oh.
My favorite was the Reggie, the Reggies.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah.
Come on.
for him to be doing all of that.
Or like what, like, let me be like one of the big machines.
And I just go,
when they're injured, you know?
And you're like, no!
No, no, my alive fridge!
No, my 17 fridge Pokemon!
Rotom, you're thinking of Rotom.
Rotom, yes.
Oh, maybe.
I always think of the Reggie Rock, because they're like,
they're like, more than 1101.01.
I hate oon, oon, oon, oon.
Oon, oon, oon.
Like, that's what I want to...
I love, I love, I think the Reggies are my favorite.
They're like...
I was talking to another friend about this, but like, when
we get audition sides, we audition for like multiple
characters, and all the time it's like, pretty Princess One,
pretty Princess Two, gremlin from the streets.
And I'm like, that's the one I want to do, and I put all of
my time into gremlin from the streets.
like you got cast as pretty princess number one and I'm like
no we don't understand what would it be sound like I don't
know like just like a little guy like I just want to be a
little guy so you should just do that they can cost you for
pretty princess number one and you could just do that you
guys yeah I smoked 45 degrees hey your boys how's it going
I'm little princess I'm five Yes, all.
Come get these gems.
Yeah.
I want a little pony ride.
Get him.
You mean the chaos emeralds?
Don't you want a little bit of this?
Daddy gave me another cigarette.
I love rainbow loops.
I'm just gonna eat my Cheerios.
I want my Fortnite free books.
Yeah.
Daddy says she's gonna get me.
Papa, I want my Fortnite battle pass.
No.
Daddy, where's my little pony?
I would watch a show about that.
I would watch a show.
Imagine a chain smoker in my little pony.
It's like, wow, Twilight Sparkle.
Hi, I'm a twi- Like, can you imagine?
Hi, your ponies.
I'm the hag from the forest.
She's probably like, well, I forgot like the harmony thing.
She's like, the- He's like, is it Selkies that are like the
weird like horses?
Oh, the pony, mermaids.
Like the mermaids, like a creepy, yeah.
I'm a Selky from the DJ.
Back in the war.
Back in the war, I was in the pony war.
That was hard, I'm winning, I'm winning.
Yeah, there's so many warriors there.
He's like, I was in the pony war.
Back then, we had riders.
And then he's just a little racist.
He's like, a zebra and then, what's it called?
A zebra and pony land.
What the fuck is this?
I never killed my mom.
Cutie mark?
It's two KitKats.
Kiss him.
I would watch a show about that.
This stream used to be about something.
It is still about something.
Now it's about...
I can tell you what it is.
It's about that grandma pony down the street.
Honestly, that's my Oshi.
My Oshi is grandma pony.
You know, we live in like a great time for indie animation.
Who's to say, you know, we take all the funding we got for
that agency.
We were trying to sell it.
Yeah.
This is the bank watching our stream as like an example of
what we can bring.
Oh my god, we've watched everything.
We actually don't have staff and I didn't answer the phone
in different voices.
Thank you for calling me.
You heard Jennifer Robbins.
I'm Jennifer Robbins.
Help me out, you bet you go.
I was like, it's almost like I was in Pony Nam.
Oh god.
Do you think we're gonna make it guys as streamers?
Do you think we're gonna make it?
of that news to you.
I thought you meant just in general, are we gonna make it?
Like actually, I say we've got six housetops.
Guys, this is our first, this is our debut stream as a first
time streamer is all.
Do you guys think we're gonna make it?
Welcome to our new small agency.
90% to the company, 10 to the pounds.
Guys, are we gonna be okay?
I don't know.
Well, to be fair, like after this, we're shopping.
Honestly, so fair.
Yeah, so.
We're probably gonna leave them.
Like the police are gonna be waiting outside.
That's true.
They've already, we streamed it up.
We've received 15 noise complaints.
They called the cops.
They're like, there's a Reggie Rock in the building.
They like geolocated our location right there.
Mom, we've had reports of the Chaos Emeralds in this
location.
You know how like we stream too long?
They're like pinpointing our address because of our stream.
One of our fans is upstairs.
I was like, you know where she is.
They're like, oh boy, the donkey bun stream is our damn
neighbors.
Yeah, they were like watching our stream while walking fast
and hearing her voice.
And we're like, wait a minute.
kind of hurts after you drop off on me too.
We're gonna be grabbing a pony from down the street.
I know, I'm gonna, it's gonna go for a two-nighter.
It's okay, we're not gonna talk.
Oh wait, we are.
I'm gonna feel her tomorrow.
Wait, we are.
We have like a talking thing tomorrow.
We've made a horrible mistake.
Oh, the day- Tomorrow I'll be fine.
Yeah, the day after tomorrow we have something we need to
talk.
Oh, you're excited to talk to people?
Yeah, unfortunately, we can't be there for you.
Oh!
You're gonna be all alone.
We won't be babysitting you until tomorrow.
okay there's a lot of pressure i don't know if i can do this
yeah we just leave it's okay you're gonna have ceo with you
yeah you have stevie with you really bad there he is ceo
yeah don't ceo where did you get stevie uh i was in cornwall
a few years back so he's cornish oh is that bad or good i
don't know much about uk geography it's good it's okay
cornwall's where everyone goes for summer holiday oh but
also like it's a holiday yeah because i also in like the
back of our minds They're like, we hope you can get out of
here one day.
Yeah, because like in UK, the only thing I know about UK is
London.
So I was like, London.
Wait, better stream idea.
Full of a blank.
A blank.
Okay, I've done this before.
I'm really bad geography.
I can't name this.
How many UK towns can you name?
A lot of suicide does not count.
I wrote a blank UK map.
It was a geogast.
Geogast, yeah.
And we were like, they're like Stonehenge.
And then we're like, where is Stonehenge?
We were like.
this one oh she's pointing to the republic of island okay
because i wasn't gonna say that so oh thank you for showing
me all right well now that i know that scotland's at top oh
yeah dublin is just nearby dublin's in england isn't it no
no no no no no no no do the the us map we were like yeah
okay we did i did geo guesser with mint for a stream and we
were like trying to figure out like obviously it was did not
look great on us and we got every South American country
wrong we were like where's that we're like Brazil we're like
there's I know that's Brazil right and then there was the
panning to the Colombian flag in the corner and we were like
Colombia yeah and then like it was a clip of it like they
like traveling and they zoom in on the Colombian flag and
we're like Oh, that's not Brazil.
We're about to cause an international incident.
Yeah, Turkey said that South America was Africa.
I had that, yeah.
Not a good look.
It was not a good look at me.
I was just like, I'm so sorry.
To be fair, I got every other region wrong.
Oh, he went right.
No, it was not equally ignorant.
Equally ignorant.
And including my own country.
They were like, name your provinces, and I only knew my own
province.
Incredible.
Yeah, because I was like, I only recognize my own province.
You know, they're just like the rest of us.
Actually, if we're looking at a UK map right now, I want, do
you know the difference between England, the UK and Great
Britain?
The silence is deafening.
Okay, United Kingdom has several countries in, well, not
countries, but...
I'm gonna eat, put a thing in my mouth.
There it is.
It's several countries, don't worry.
Several countries united into a kingdom.
That's why it's United Kingdom, you know?
It's weird.
because the United Kingdom is a country made up of other
countries, so we don't know what the fuck we're doing.
And then Great Britain is where England is.
I guess if you- Yeah, Great Britain is where England-
Listen, it's called the United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland for a reason.
Let's just put it that way.
See, I know my geography.
Yeah, no, this is England.
Once you've chopped off though, we're looking at a map of
just England and not like, Gone.
Scotland has been abolished.
Yeah.
Well, like, everywhere it's just an island.
The UK's just a fucking giant ass... Now name all the
problems.
It's a giant ass island.
It's a what?
It's an island!
You gotta be careful.
You gotta be careful saying that.
It's just an island.
It is.
You gotta be careful saying island because that could also
mean this place.
No, I'm saying the UK.
It's just... It's like a big...
Well, I guess that would make every continent an island, no?
That's true.
Is Australia an island?
I'm 14 and this is Yeah, there's John as, it's like New
Zealand is an island.
True.
Listen, all I'm saying is there's a little something called
the Troubles we don't want to bring up again, so let's be
careful.
What is Turkey?
I'm Asian.
All right.
I'm also very far away from the phone.
Yeah, remember when she came in, she's like, and she's like,
whoa.
Like her eyes were like that.
Yeah, and then I'm like,
whoa.
And this guy's like, whoa.
is why playing with your parameters on your model is worth
it i have to always change your mind to be like less severe
i'm like oh yeah but it works for me thank god it works for
me yeah no i did like one time a chat asked me to name the
states in america oh not go so well i've done that before
and it's i was just like that's texas that's texas too and
then i was like and then i put I think I put like Carolina
like three times.
West Virginia.
East Virginia.
You got New York, right?
South Virginia.
Yeah, I got New York.
I was like one of these is New York.
I know it was up there.
And I remember someone, I remember there's like, I thought
there was a Nerf in South State of something and they're
like, that doesn't exist.
And I was like, Carolina.
There's North Carolina and South Carolina.
Yeah, no, there was one first one of them.
I don't remember which one.
Is it South Virginia?
Wait, is there South Virginia?
East Virginia.
There's West Virginia.
And then I was like, what about Northeast and West Virginia?
West Dakota.
There's just West Virginia.
And then there's District of Columbia.
I know there's North Virginia.
There's like the capital.
Yeah.
And I was like, why is there only one direction of the
state?
Where are the other ones?
Honestly, so fair.
It's because they're like, joking, that state does not
exist.
I was like, why is there North Virginia?
There's North Dakota.
Why?
I thought of the last one.
That's the time that like the the capital was in New York.
There is just Virginia and then West.
I don't understand what's going on with you.
Yeah.
There's New York.
Where's Old York?
Yeah, exactly.
Well, if there is a new one, there's the old one.
Old York is in England.
It's just called York.
No, that's true because they were a colony.
So that's why New York was New York because they- You've
taken a lot of our place names for the record.
Like, wait, that makes a lot of sense.
I wonder where the original went.
Old Hampshire back in Britain.
It's just called Hampshire.
We don't call it, oh, what are we going to call our new
town, Old Hampshire?
That's a bit of a weird choice.
Okay.
That's why it's new, it's better.
I love history.
I'm like, there's also, oh, no.
So we have a Birmingham, and the US has a Birmingham, and
the VXPO, which is the, basically the British VTuberCon, is
held in Birmingham in the UK, and naming no names, I do know
someone who has accidentally flown out to Birmingham, I
think, Virginia, instead of flying to, like, the American.
The European Convention and they flew to America?
They flew to Birmingham, they just didn't ask which one.
You would think, you know, they're like...
That's pretty great.
You're like in the middle of... Is it Alabama?
Yeah, one of them.
You would think like, you know, the Europe's first VTuber
Convention, you would think it'd be in Europe.
They're like, oh, wait a second.
It's weird.
It's like, oh, it's quite long.
Yeah, wait a minute.
I thought I...
Wait a second.
Wait, are they... Were they from Europe?
I'm not sure why she's she's based right now but she flies
all the way to America she's like 14 hours but I'm finally
ready for VX oh that's that's a little there's a lot of
place names that I'm like oh this is a normal English town
and then I go to like America or something like why do you
have one of those like Ontario, California, and there's
Ontario, like, obviously, like, Canada.
You guys just take up our names.
There's only so many names, I guess, in the world.
Yeah, but you guys can.
You know what, guys?
When I take over the world, when I'm president of the United
States.
But it gets weird.
You're like, oh, let me go.
Let me head over to Paris, Texas.
Yeah, you're getting there.
Oh, yeah.
You're getting there.
Paris, Texas.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Yep.
Next year, I can run for president, guys, and then I'll
change all the names.
Yeah.
Have you considered running for mayor first, so then at
least you get to, like, have the experience of cutting those
big ribbons with those huge scissors.
I've had to go with those those big novelty checks.
I've always wanted to do that.
I think you can trust me with big scissors for sure.
I think I can trust you.
You're not, you know, you're not dead yet, so.
I'm half half there.
I don't want to hear any opinions about like who's clumsy
from the one who spilled our food earlier.
No, yeah, but obviously it's someone spilled in.
Yeah, someone sabotaged me.
Right, right, sitting by yourself in the middle someone
curious you don't have a fucking keyboard block the app of
your you have a little something it's called knees i'm not
putting it on my knees i'm already obstructed by a keyboard
in front of me yeah look at all the table space you two have
we could have shared we could have shared i offered to share
my meal with you that's real it's true right now i had i had
food earlier things have transpired which can never be
undone i did i did it yeah yeah yeah yeah Oh, she said, oh,
they're in Japan!
What the?
Get them anywhere.
Yeah, you get them anywhere.
But I could be...
Red bobbing them.
Which one?
You'll never know.
It could be a red heron.
I could have literally just said where we were, but then now
we're playing it off.
Remember during the cardboard boxes behind us?
The Japanese cardboard boxes.
We'll just let chicken on this one.
Wait a second.
We're moving, guys.
We're actually roomies.
We're going to be roomies together.
That's our announcement.
Whenever it's announced, it's like- We're moving into the
White House because I'm running for president.
We're making a streamer house.
Ooh.
A VTuber streamer house.
Wait, stream a house.
But it is the White House would go insane for a concept.
Yeah, but too bad, like we can't show any of that.
Okay, we just, we need to start our agency that's like
president VTuber, vice president VTuber, secretary of state
VTuber.
I'd actually be pretty much- I'd like to be- I like to be
the secretary of war.
I'm the speaker of the house.
I'm the guy who rakes up the leaves on the front lawn.
Every day when you do the like the announcement and stuff,
you do a nude voice.
And every day you actually just get this one.
And then, you know how the poly market, they bet on stuff.
And so they're like, what voice is Avali going to do next on
poly market?
10,000 Bitcoin for Avali to do toad.
Avali is going to do toad today.
As an English person who's had to live through, how do we
say, the rotating door of prime ministers a few years back,
this is from this heading pretty close to home.
Do you know about the time that our, basically our prime
minister was just replaced with a cabbage?
What?
Yeah, we had a bit of a rotating door for like heads of
state for a hot minute.
And basically someone- Head of state, head of cabbage, get
it?
Basically someone set up a thing where it was like, what's
going to happen first?
This cabbage is going to go off, or the prime minister is
going to get kicked out of office.
You'll never guess who lasted longer.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
The cat always trusted the cabbage.
Goodbye, let's trust.
My cabbage.
Come on, cabbages.
Oh my God, that's crazy.
The prime minister graduates it.
No, I don't think that's how that works.
Well, actually.
I can't really graduate it, guys.
Oh my God.
I can.
There's a lettuce joke here.
There's a lettuce.
Let us vote.
Is he gonna reincarnate?
Is he, it's like, kind of as the lettuce.
As the lettuce?
Yeah, like my president reincarnated into a lettuce.
It's a great anime.
I know I was thinking that, but...
Finally, Sakai is good again.
Our vice president is ahead of me.
Cabbage.
That'll be good.
That'll be a good one.
It's pretty great.
I love the segments of this stream have just evolved into...
We just talk.
The thing is...
Well and truly just chatting shit.
Yeah.
We're not drunk, by the way.
If you guys want to know.
We're fully sober.
We're very...
I don't know if that's worse or better.
I mean, we can't even say what time of day it is, like, to
disprove anything.
We could be drinking in the morning or at night.
I forgot.
You know, I had my- It's minus two in the morning.
I had my staff make the waiting room for this because you
can tell, you can see what time zone you're in by the
waiting room you make.
So I had my staff make the waiting room.
Tricky, tricky.
Yes.
So they dampened with like, wait, this waiting room.
See, I would have missed.
I'm glad that you did it because I would have fucked that
up.
I'm not gonna lie.
I would have, you would have found out real fast.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
She's at the cell phone.
They actually don't know.
Clever, clever.
Guys, we're in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean.
We're in Antarctica.
Please help.
We're actually on an oil rig.
An oil rig.
We're on a cruise right now.
We're on a cruise.
We're on, what was it, Northern Lion Cruise?
Oh no.
Yeah, it got canceled, but it was actually, they brought it
back for like other content creators.
Yeah, for other content creators.
So it's just other content creators and Northern Lion.
And VTuber Streamer House, no, no, no.
Oh, it has to be really bad.
You'll never guess who we know Northern Lions through.
Imagine, like, the ping, though, for online games.
That would be really...
I was going to say, because, like, the whole Northern Lion
Cruise was the fact that, like, they'll be streaming on the
cruise.
Oh, my God.
So, yeah, but then it got canceled, obviously, because,
like, people were making, like, threatening tweets about
what they're going to do on the Northern Lion Cruise.
So it became a safety hazard.
I feel like maybe they should have seen that one coming.
Yeah, because they're, like, I'm going to get really sick.
I'm going to release a new pathogen in the northern lion
cruise.
I'm putting these vessels in all the water, baby.
You know how everybody's going to.
You know how there was a hunt, the Haunted Virus that, you
know how it came to be?
It was like on a cruise ship?
Yeah, no, it's- Nothing good happens on a cruise ship,
right?
Yeah, okay, so it was like this one guy was a bird watcher
and when the cruise docked, the guy went to a landfill to
watch birds.
Yeah, and there's rats there.
So then to get the Haunted Virus, it's not like bodily
fluids or anything, it's just the smell of a rat.
It's a smell?
Yeah, it's a smell.
Oh god.
You sniff, like, so then there's so many rats.
They were right.
Yeah, the plague.
That is how you get the plague.
Oh my god.
How insightful.
Guys, nobody sniffed.
Yeah, so basically the guy was, there was just so many rats.
So him and his wife got the Hantha virus and then brought it
to the cruise and then obviously.
Oh, snap.
And then nothing else happened.
Yeah.
And then, so that's basically why the Northern Lion Cruise
was getting to some people who were tweeting how they were
bringing another path.
They were sniffing Because they were going to bring another
pathogen in the cruise, so they're like, that's not good.
Oh my god.
Oh, no, no, no.
Like four birds?
Like you brought back a fucking- They're on vacate, you're
going to a landmine?
Yeah, landfill.
Landfill, sorry, a landmine.
The birds were going on vacation there.
Yeah.
So I had to see them.
That's like Scotland's for them.
Rats, rats.
We are the rats.
Yeah.
Do you think he was celebrating another birthday bash?
A birthday bash?
For what?
Michael, it's your birthday.
We don't know the German rats song.
Oh, sickening.
No, the four lyrics of the rat song.
Rats.
We are the rats.
It's a song.
It's a birthday today.
Shaking ice cream is out of its way.
And Michael, you've been a good boy this year.
Wait, do you know the whole song?
She knows the whole song.
Keep going.
That's it.
I didn't know it was a song.
It was a song.
It was from, was it, was it German?
Yes.
I've only ever heard of red German.
It's always from German.
Every single year on my birthday, I get that from one of my
friends.
I'm like, all right, boss.
Yeah.
My name isn't even Michael.
It's John.
It's always from German.
It's always from extended version, 10 hours.
I don't even know the extended version.
I didn't know it was even a song.
Where did you heard that?
Just the meme.
Like, rats, rats.
We got a rat.
Did you ever see the video?
No.
She's never seen the video.
Okay.
I'm getting copyright strike.
I would rather get copyright strike.
Straight from Gerber.
I didn't know Bandicoon, guys.
Of course I don't know the rat meme.
Rat.
We have a lot of rat memes.
I like your mom, and you have to explain like, Alright,
Grandma, let's get you to bed.
That's not the one I was thinking of.
I was thinking of the birthday one.
Oh I'm thinking of the birthday one.
That makes all of the rules.
Where was my audition for this?
Oh, the giant rat that makes all of the rules.
You will never be fitted ourselves into it.
Where was my audition for this?
Rat, rat.
See, can I, show you the one that i've been thinking okay
yeah oh wait no it will just be this one but oh that's the
other version we are the rats celebrating in a birthday
match he looks like a kid possible rat
i've never seen that congrats i know both of them i know
congrats now you know both of them
birthday rats and the other rats we are the rats how does he
do that little voice rats we are the rats i like it's just
michael jennifer here jennifer robber's husband that's is
our demo reel cat us let us in let us in the league we'll be
the rats i've always wanted to be a rat cast me a rat flu yo
we could be the background rats in any show you're doing
Jennifer Roberts' husband.
There's a whole movie attached to these songs.
That's a whole movie?
There is.
Jerma's videography is interesting.
And let's leave it at that.
Okay, okay.
Whoa.
Jerma is an anomaly or so, I'm told.
People keep comparing me to Jerma, and I don't know if it's
a compliment or a damning insult.
I think it's a compliment.
He is a very...
I remember the one Jerma video is where he did like huge...
He created a huge, like, doll house.
Yes.
set i don't know if you ever see ever okay basically it's
like a live action thing he's created like an actual
physical like life-sized doll oh wow so he's pretending to
be a sim and chat controls it yeah what and it is very
stupid it's it's crazy okay so it's like chat you know how
chat plays pokemon yeah chat plays germa okay okay jump out
a window at one point it's great yeah yeah oh my god the one
thing i remember the most from he just does whatever the he
wants he like comes shows up does what he wants disappears
for like five months and then he's like semi-retired yeah He
comes out of the nursing home to play, like, whatever.
You can just be like...
You can be a streamer.
You can.
You can do anything.
Believe in yourself.
Yeah, believe in yourself.
Never apologize for who you are.
You can be a rat, too.
You too can be Jerma one day.
Really?
Even me.
Even you can be British Jerma.
Golly.
That's incredible, that is.
Yeah.
Pointered him in the pool and removed the lamp.
How did your eyes vanish that fast?
I don't know.
What?
I just kept sipping.
I just know my nose got in me.
Oh, God.
Rice.
Brace.
Ah!
I'm bringing the haunted virus.
Nose ASMR.
Cruise ship.
She was sniffing all the rats.
Where's the cruise ship?
She was sniffing the rats.
Oh, it was fun.
It was fun.
It was been a fun off collab.
We were like, I was a little worried.
Like, what were you taking me to do?
I was also a little worried.
Yeah.
But I, you, we had a couple ideas.
And I was like, we were going to do a eating.
ASMR first.
We're like order some food and then but then we couldn't
tell you guys chips.
Yeah, we couldn't tell you guys exactly what food we order.
We had to be like nondescript.
She has got McDonald's or something.
It's like that's everywhere.
But usually like crunchy or like noise though.
Yeah, we're like let's open this nondescriptive chip bag
here.
Oh, I wonder what flavor it is.
It's a very generic flavor from a local convenience store.
find it quite inconvenient actually yeah but then we
realized after this we have to move a lot so then we're like
maybe we shouldn't eat like we did eat we're going skiing we
couldn't do eating we're doing rhythm gymnastics yeah where
we got we got like a we're actually in town for the uh the
Olympics yeah we got invited to do something for the
Olympics that's why we're here we're training for it
unfortunately uh they didn't specify that it was the sports
yeah now I have to learn how to do trampolining.
Yeah, we're going to be at the opening for the Olympics.
So that's why they got us three here.
They flew us all the way.
They're going to have us bouncing on the beds like in
London.
We're just three trees.
We're going to call, we're waiting for our call right now.
Any moment now.
Right now, guys.
We're just three of the trees.
Right after this stream, like, the we're trying on our tree.
Yeah, we're going to try a tree suit and like
but it was like because it's like, it's like, we're all
calling five.
Get ready.
You're gonna be spruce, you're gonna be alpine.
Are you ready for the Olympic opening, you guys?
What if, like, what if, like, when the opening shows up, we
take a screenshot and just circle three random people.
Did you see it?
We have our VTuber faces, like, really small.
Red star with the red arrow.
We circle three random people.
It's like, that's us.
Holy fuck!
I'm gonna take a photo of three random trees later.
These are our outfits.
The metamorphosis is complete.
I've always wanted to be a tree.
Oh my God.
It'll be fun.
I mean, it'll be fun in the Olympics, guys.
I can't believe we got that offer.
What sports do they have these days?
They have esports now.
Oh, of course.
Yeah.
But then, do you know they have esports for the Olympics?
What?
Yeah.
But the crazy part is that the games for it is like just
sport games.
Wait.
Like with virtual basketball?
Yeah, like the NBA.
Yeah, I'm thinking away sports.
Well, it's sort of like that.
It's not like.
It's like, it's not League of Legends.
No, they don't.
It's not League.
It's really like sport games, like game, like just video
games based on particular sports.
What if it was like...
Let me show you.
What if it was like Olympic Mario Party?
Or like...
No, I don't want to go to the Olympic Winter Games.
Olympic Mario Party or Olympic like Mario Party go crazy.
Half of them were our mobile games too.
So people were like, I mean, You got any games on your
phone?
Yeah, we have giant consoles.
We have huge computers.
Bring the points.
I'm ready for tennis, guys.
It's like Olympic candy crush.
Like, why are we?
You know, did you hear about the break dancing in the
Olympics?
I think so.
Yeah, they literally took it up.
They took it away.
They added it and then took it away.
So funny.
Because of the Australian.
And like, she wasn't even the best.
Go, white girl, go, white girl, go.
No, white girl, go.
I don't think I could have done a better job.
Yeah, we love.
But like, hmm.
No, but she wasn't even the best break dancer in Australia.
Of course not.
She was just full nepotism.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, she was like her husband was on the board or
something.
In all of the island of Australia.
In all of Australia, we were only able to sit.
Entire island.
We only had one.
Yeah.
There was only one person that knew how to break dance and
that's a portion of it.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Okay.
No, no Australian knows how to break dance.
They are, they all chose like, like Samba or something, like
ballroom dancing.
Ballroom dancing.
Yeah, and everything.
Square dancing.
I know that, um, I know that like in the Olympics, they
always add like one to two new sports to start it off.
I wonder what it is for.
Marble rivals this season.
If there's no league, I don't think there would be marbles.
I'm thinking Peggle.
Peggle?
Does anyone know in chat what the Mews sport they added?
Is it Olympic Jenga?
Because like the last Olympic was the great dance one.
Yeah, what's the new one?
Yeah, what's the new?
They always add one to two new ones.
I think my favorite Olympic sport to watch is...
Is flag football?
In football?
Flag, flag football.
Just play regularly.
Like, flag.
Also, like, I love this that they have to like make a team.
It's like, you know, you wear the flags and then, yes, I
played this in recent.
I play like this at peace.
I played this in middle school.
They see how he grabs.
Like, oh, okay.
Wait, I played them.
You have like belts on you have to like grab.
Yeah, you're gonna have to pull it and then they're in jail.
They get knocked out.
That's insane.
They've actually just added Capture the Flag.
It's literally Capture the Flag.
Just like, yeah, dude, that's crazy.
Can you imagine being like, wow, my mom's an Olympic, like
Olympian.
Oh yeah, what's the board?
How supposed to non-Olympian Olympians.
Capture the Flag.
I love that.
Well, I mean, we love, but like, again, none of us, I don't
even know.
No, none of us.
I feel like, but it's like, as long as you can, I feel like
that's something, a rugby.
Basically, if you play rugby, you play this.
That's fair.
Like, if you're a, I guess it's like, because like they
don't have rugby, right, at the Olympics.
I don't know.
So this is like the baby rugby.
Yeah, you should play baby rugby.
But then on the other hand, that means that everyone
competing probably has like 17 concussions.
That's true, because you can't wear helmets for this.
There's some sports that don't make sense to me.
The one that gets to me is bob sledding.
It's like a canoe with like ice skates.
Yeah.
It's like, yeah, let's try to commute in giant place.
How do you guys invent this?
But for a box sled, the thing about it is that it's just
body weight.
So you just have to have the perfect body to do body.
Like, I remember seeing like...
I don't drink too much water before you get on the sled,
haven't I?
It doesn't really matter, like...
Olympic paintball.
The Olympic...
Holy shit, they got Sputuna this one.
Wait, Olympic laser tag would actually go fucking crazy.
No, do you know, like, how there's extreme...
Not extreme, sorry, there's, like, actual sporting events
for tag in general?
No.
No, it's hardcore.
Oh, what's that?
Kabaddi.
That's kind of that gift.
I'll show you the video of it's crazy.
I don't think I can show it on because then it'll play on
the stream.
No, yeah, that reminds me of Kabaddi.
And it would be.
No, it's crazy.
They built like this giant like venue for it and everything.
And it's like, it's like, oh my god, I haven't seen this.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Parkour.
So the guy, they're just just chasing him all around.
It's just tag.
Parkour.
It's extreme tag.
Me and my mates go into the play.
They're both British.
I would face plant immediately.
Like, I would run in there and face plant.
Well, we've got bad news.
That's just what you all signed up for.
They're playing, this is Olympic dead by daylight.
That's true.
No, dead by daylight.
It's just tag.
It's the chat.
Oh, God.
The trappers on me.
Oh, do the jams, do the jams.
Quickly.
Push the, he's like, push down.
Oh, my God.
The trappers are on me.
It's crazy.
No, there's some crazy sports.
I'm trying.
I remember I talked about some of them in chat because I was
like, bro, this is crazy.
Like, some of the weirdest.
as like, like, not Olympic, but just extreme sports that
people do.
Chad, do you guys remember some of the things I brought up?
I remember, I mean, the obvious one's slapping, because
everyone remember.
Oh, yeah, the slapping is crazy.
The slapping, people can actually get concussions from it.
I think people, like, literally got, like, like, actual
brain damage from the whole thing.
Like, like, it's insane.
Some of those slaps are insane.
I was like, whoa.
Have you seen one of those?
I don't know that I have.
It's just, it's usually in Russia.
It's like...
Yeah, I said a lot of them are in Prague.
a slap at the power of a freight train yeah so it's just
you're just like I think I'm good and they they do the
slow-mo so you see the face like ripping and like the
eyeballs bulging out of people's heads and it's like yeah
dragons do you guys remember any of the funny sports I
talked about because I bookmarked some stuff you know like
on Twitter it pops out and I bookmarked them and I'd be like
I gotta talk about this what the fuck is this I love the dog
sports I love watching the dog sports like the dog doing
like the I was gonna say dress up.
Oh, they're like a trainer.
I'm doing like dog shows.
Those are great.
Cause they're fast.
Yeah.
I always love it when it's a dog that you're not like a
great Dane.
Like you're like you're not expecting that breed.
You're like, yeah, go get them, boy.
It's like Chihuahua doing a, you know.
They're just extreme ironing.
Is this what, like a speed run?
You just, were you ironing clothes?
Ironing?
Yeah.
Extreme ironing.
You're just ironing.
I think anything could be an extreme sport if you just push
it to its absolute limit.
Yeah, but it's on like, what's it called?
I kind of love that.
extreme cable management because i think i could really be
the head of that someone's got to have done something like
that at some point like the rock paper scissors world
championship or something i mean that's fun i saw the
ostrich racing but then that was just like oh so like you
know how there's horse racing so i think it's this is in
america so like every once a year they do like like they
they do like what random animals for it instead of horses
ostriches yeah and one of like there's one with ostriches
and then there was one with giraffes wait i'll show you i
like the horse race yes it's in america where do they get
the giraffes in america at a zoo i like the horse races
where you just get the jockeys off the horses and they just
have to run where is peter when you need them what is peter
doing i remember the ostrich and giraffe one and then i
think there was one with zebras and stuff it was crazy i was
just like what the oh yeah there's one with Wait, that's not
the one.
This is someone else.
Some of those look AI.
No, the ones I showed, this was pre-AI when I was watching
it.
This is pre-AI.
Back in my day.
Here.
Wait, alright.
See if I...
What the fuck?
Guess the game?
I actually pressed the guess the game from one second of
music.
Okay, here.
This is literally the... This is ostrich.
Oh, yeah, they're in the gates.
Oh, they're riding them.
Yeah, actually.
Yeah, those are ostriches, yep.
You can ride an ostrich?
That guy couldn't try.
That's a fucking chocobo.
Oh my god, they're dropping off the ostrich.
Like, there's humans just falling off the ostriches.
Oh, Lord.
They're just dropping to the ground.
Yeah, and they're like, we did our best.
Are those jockeys at three feet tall?
Like, how are they fitting on these ostriches?
Yeah, skill, baby.
Yeah.
So they would do, like, themed, they would do themed animals
every year.
And I guess that day was ostriches.
next one's gonna be like cobras we're gonna be racing cobras
I remember these because I was watching it on I was talking
to my stream about wiener dog races and then because those
exist too but like you don't ride the wiener dog I hope not
which which voting count what what voting council do I have
to be on to choose the animal of the year because I like to
volunteer what should we do this we're doing crocodiles guys
should the Peter dragon races look everyone
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I remember my chat was like, have you seen ostrich racing?
It's like ostrich?
What?
Ostrich race?
I was like, oh, it's humans riding them.
What the?
Did you think they were just going to be like loose?
Yeah.
They were loose?
Like, oh, like dog racing.
I didn't think you could ride.
I thought that their bones were too fragile.
Like, they're like, they're big, like fragile dinosaurs.
I'm going to have pretty strong bones because they could run
out for us.
It's fair.
They're pretty big.
I think it would like hold the weight of a human though.
Let me see.
It was just like small children.
Oh, like that's, that's danger.
That's like, that's what you have to call.
Toddlers.
What was the service, the child, like where they could call
someone?
Oh, child services.
Yeah.
Child protective services.
They're with PETA.
Yeah.
You're like, oh.
They're like, all right, boys, lock everybody up.
There's something going on.
Yeah.
CPS.
PSN PETA for me to dust a duo.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my gosh.
I did not.
It's 1230.
Okay.
We had the end.
Yeah.
I was just like, oh my gosh.
We were successfully yapping.
Yeah.
We're two hours straight.
We went through a lot of topics.
Yeah.
Well, guys, you'll have to just wait and see to see what
we're working on.
Or don't.
Like that's also an option.
No, it's false.
Yeah.
Or not working on, I guess.
Maybe we won't have to come back.
a lot of money but we didn't get the loan unfortunately but
we got flat this time oh the snail took all the money so
anyway we're gonna be flying out to another country tomorrow
yeah different bank in a different country yeah different
we're going to Switzerland tomorrow someone will take us
someone will give us the loan we're actually giving Doki a
blank map which is gonna point to our mom I'm like I bet
there is a millionaire living there Someone won't give us a
load.
Be too, we're in your area.
All right, everybody.
We're gonna head off now.
We hope you all had.
I just realized all of us are from different countries.
Yeah.
Just realized.
I just realized that.
Yeah, we're all from different, I was gonna say different
continents, but that I realized we're both from the same
life.
We gotta go back to the math.
I was joking.
And again, there's like peace.
After you do this, Emily, but wow.
I don't know if you know that.
No, I don't even know if you know this.
But while we were in here, Canada, there was an earthquake
at the border between Canada.
America split off.
We're the new Pangaea.
It's an island now.
It's an island.
It's their own continent.
We drifted over to Asia.
We're there.
You know, when Pangaea broke apart.
Pretty sure this is the shit the dinosaurs went through.
Yeah, yeah.
I was gonna say, yeah, we're in a new Pangaea.
We drifted apart.
Littlefoot, no.
Oh, no.
Thank you all for coming to stream.
Thank you for coming to Emily's first off collab.
Yeah, yippee!
And Jennifer Roberts' day do stream.
Yes!
We're gonna have to close things out.
Can we get it back in here for two seconds?
Jennifer Roberts!
The people want you.
The people want you, Jen.
We're closing shop.
The people are requesting you.
That's your last shop.
We're gonna say goodbye.
We're closing shop.
You have to say goodbye.
You can call Sebastian Snow.
You have to graduate.
One of these days, I'm gonna have just the worst idea ever.
to actually call that number and see if it still has.
Wait, I must, I have to be in the room.
I'll be really good, I promise.
I'll be really quiet.
Hey there, how you doing?
I know DonkeyBad.
Wait, no.
No, no.
Do you think, do you think you can see me like four bottles
about a call?
We can do that.
We can talk.
You can do it.
Do you think that's just that we'll sue us.
We're just like this person.
Yeah, because you'd be like, why am I on this random VTV
stream?
He would.
He would sue me because it's my channel.
It wasn't me.
It was Jokie Bird.
It was Jokie Bird who saw her mouth moving as I told the
story.
I mean, she told the story.
That's true.
That's right.
I did tell that story.
They're still live.
Oh!
I picked this myself when it's published.
Thank you.
He received cringes.
Oh, all right.
What do you guys, I'm like?
I'm taking this.
All right.
Just for the emergency delivery of little dudes.
Oh my God.
Thank you.
Thank you, Amelie's third mom.
Is it fourth mom?
We got four gifts.
We got gifts from her fourth mom.
Oh, I am.
What a happy family.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
All right, guys.
And on that bombshell.
All right.
We're going to head off now.
Thank you, everybody.
how many moms does she have not enough agree i have all of
the moms the big mom mommy bag magnet over here yeah all
right guys we're gonna head off thank you everybody for
coming to the opera we all had so much fun as always maybe
consider getting like a hearing checked at home yeah i can't
wait to re-watch this bot just to see how the volume yeah
like bad it is yeah yeah it's just like You can't hear
anything.
I'm sure it is.
My sound guy was like, it's as good as it can get.
Which doesn't mean it's good.
But thank you to Rin and Amelie for both coming.
And Jennifer Roberts.
And Jennifer Roberts for Amelie's fourth mom.
And third mom is second.
All of my mom.
Yeah, yeah.
For the food and the food.
All right, guys, we're gonna head off.
Bye everybody.
Have a good one.
Bye.
Bye, bye.
Do you know which button is?
Is this one?